So Leute, ich bin am Start wieder.
Heute geht es mir besser als gestern.
Man hört es glaube ich ein bisschen, erkält bin ich immer noch,
aber im Großen und Ganzen ist eigentlich ganz okay wieder.
Also ich denke mal spätestens irgendwie so Montag oder so ist das wieder alles weg.
Hört man mich überhaupt? Ja, gut.
Ja, da ist nämlich manchmal der Meinung, mein Audio-Interface kriegt einen anderen Namen,
weil Windows denkt, das muss so sein.
Uh, da haben wir ganz schön viele Fragen von gestern auch drin.
Muss ich mal im Eck schmeißen.
Kommt eventuell bald ein neues PC-Kaufberatungsvideo?
Oh boy.
Da gibt es, ich glaube, da gibt es mittlerweile genug andere, die gute Videos machen.
Von Hardware-Rad bis ein paar englische Channels.
Ihr habt es doch gestern mitgekriegt, ich bin doch selbst nicht auf dem Laufenden.
Ich bin nur auf dem Laufenden.
Und wenn es darum geht, wenn ich mir einen neuen Rechner kaufen will.
Oh, das ist, äh, Main, das ist eine gute Frage.
Kannst du diese Frage nochmal mit AdWublo ausstellen,
dass die dann auch eben in meinem Fragen-Log drin ist?
Ja, das gucken wir uns gleich an.
Ich räume erstmal die Fragen auf und bis dahin ist der Stream wahrscheinlich auch so richtig online,
weil Twitch braucht immer ein bisschen mit Notifications und so alles.
Das ist eine gute Frage. Das ist eine wirklich gute Frage.
Ähm, da kann man ein bisschen was zu erzählen.
Hatten wir schon beantwortet.
Haben wir gestern auch geguckt.
Ist da überhaupt eine Frage drin, die man...
Ja, Partnerbewerbung. Ich glaube, das mache ich das Wochenende echt.
Ach, der Patrick ist da. Da können wir uns den Discord auch angucken, wenn genug Leute da sind.
Das E-Grill ist weg.
Ach, das gestern im Cod-Stream.
Ja, das können wir heute mit Discord machen.
Da ist gestern eigentlich schon was rausgekommen von der New World Order 108.
Hat das dann funktioniert?
Fandst du immer Triage oder Infinity Warfare?
Ich fand beide gut, solange die Games gut waren.
Ice-Tag-Claw ist immer noch am Start, ja.
So, gleich haben wir alles weg von gestern.
Ähm, genau.
Dann können wir uns jetzt mal, bevor wir den Rest durchklicken,
mal der Frage von Main widmen.
Der hat nämlich gefragt, ähm...
Kann mir jemand erklären, wie es sein kann, dass ich im TS per Ping kein Packet-Loss habe,
in Spielen jedoch um die 10%.
Ähm, also das kann natürlich ganz unterschiedliche Ursachen haben.
Ping ist generell...
Also, so richtig gut feststellen kann man das mit dem Ping nicht.
Ähm, weil Ping schickt einfach nicht genug Pakete.
Ähm, also...
Wenn du, wenn du einen Packet-Loss von 10% hast, dann würdest du sagen,
okay, dann müsste theoretisch jedes, jedes zehnte Paket verloren gehen.
Aber oftmals ist es nur, wenn du wirklich ordentlich viele Pakete überträgst, dass das auffällt.
Außerdem kommt dazu, ähm, dass, ähm, bei manchen Protokollen Packet-Loss nicht schlimm ist und bei manchen schon.
Also, wenn du zum Beispiel sowas hast wie, sagen wir mal, ein YouTube-Video oder sowas,
ähm, dann ist das fast egal, ob du Packet-Loss hast.
Du wirst keine Aussetzer groß...
Also, zumindest bei 10% Packet-Loss nicht wirklich.
Und 10% ist schon ganz schön viel, ja.
Ähm, wirst du keine großartigen Aussetzer merken.
Ähm, weil, wenn Pakete unterwegs verloren geht, werden die einfach nochmal geschickt.
Bei, nennen wir es mal, Echtzeit-Geschichten ist das ein bisschen anders.
Also, wir sind gerade bei der Frage hier.
Bei Sachen, die quasi...
Wo es egal ist oder wo es nicht egal ist in, äh...
Also, wo es nicht drauf ankommt so richtig, ob der Kram in der richtigen Reihenfolge ankommt oder das alles ankommt,
ähm, dann macht man das nicht, weil es ist, ähm, theoretisch zumindest für die Performance besser.
Und wenn man sich überlegt, man hat sowas wie einen Live-Feed von Audio oder einen Live-Feed von einem Video
oder eben auch...
Freunde, wir haben wirklich einérerשל guerreure大的 Daten von...
von einem Spiel.
Und, ähm, ich bekomme jetzt Pakete geschickt vom Server und, ähm, es kommt Pal...
Keine Ahnung, es kommt Paket 10 an...
vor...
vor Paket neun.
Dann wärs ja eigentlich, ähm...
Logisch irgendwo, oder ist eigentlich Logisch, dass...
dass ich damit Paket neun nicht mal anfangen kann.
Also wenn Pakete zu spät ankommen, ist egal.
Und, ähm, es bringt auch nichts, wenn ich Paket neun neu anfordere...
wenn's überhaupt nicht ankommt weil...
was interessiert mich ist, äh..
äh, wenn jetzt irgendwie Pakete noch vor Ideen kommen,cause... achievement, akchemicale Wartezeit getroffen worden.
nicht Bilddaten von vor zwei Sekunden, wenn ich schon aktuelle Bilddaten habe.
Oder bei Spielen, ja.
Was interessiert mich, dass vor zwei Sekunden irgendjemand da den Noob-Tube abgeschossen hat,
wenn der Server-Stage schon viel weiter ist.
Also deswegen wirkt sich halt, wenn man überhaupt Packet-Loss hat,
wirkt sich das eben auf solche Sachen natürlich dann auch besonders aus.
Man muss allerdings sagen, wenn du 10% Packet-Loss hast, ist wahrscheinlich alles davon betroffen.
Das kann natürlich auch sein, dass das nur auftritt, wenn du besonders viel Pakete schickst.
Nichtsdestotrotz verursachen Spiele nicht viel Traffic.
Ist YouTube UDP oder TCP?
YouTube ist sowas von TCP, weil YouTube ist HTTP.
Das wollte ich jetzt gerade sagen.
Ja, also es kann sein, dass das natürlich erst auftritt, wenn du besonders viele Pakete verschickst.
Oder dass dein Provider Probleme kriegt.
Allerdings, auch wenn es irgendwie das Gerücht sind,
sich hartnäckig hält, dass Spiele irgendwie sonderlich ressourcenintensiv wären,
das betrifft nicht den Netzwerk-Part.
Also Spiele verbrauchen so gut wie kein Netzwerk-Traffic.
Es sei denn, das ist so eine bisschen veraltete Architektur,
wie das zum Beispiel immer noch in Call of Duty ist,
dass irgendwie einer der Leute selbst das Spiel hostet.
Wobei das in Call of Duty, glaube ich, auch nicht mehr überall der Fall ist.
Aber bei dem Stream, den wir gestern gesehen haben,
war das wieder so, wenn du jetzt selbst die Sache hostest,
dann brauchst du natürlich deutlich mehr Netzwerk-Traffic.
Also logisch, dann musst du ja quasi an die ganzen Typen,
die auch bei dir in den Sessions joinen, das verteilen.
Aber in normalen Spielen ist das nicht der Fall.
Das heißt, in normalen Games braucht Spielen kaum Netzwerk-Traffic.
Und es ist relativ wahrscheinlich, dass du bei allem deine 10% Packet-Loss hast.
Allerdings, dass man das wirklich gut feststellen kann,
musst du schon mal eine ordentliche Menge an Paketen schicken.
Und es ist auch die Frage, ab wann der Loss als Loss zählt letztendlich.
Weil, wie ich gesagt habe, in Spielen, wenn du da Pakete kriegst,
die nicht in der richtigen Reihenfolge sind,
und du dann irgendwann mal das Paket kriegst,
was theoretisch reinpassen würde in die Reihenfolge, dann ist es egal.
Weil dann ist das Overstate eh schon weiter.
Äh.
Ein Ping kann durchaus, oder darf durchaus auch mal eine Sekunde unterwegs sein.
Was natürlich bei einem Spiel irgendwie recht bescheuert ist.
Traceroute sagt mir, dass ich bei zwei Vodafone-Servern rund 30% habe.
Die meinen halt, dass das normal sei, weil der Server beschädigt ist und die Anfrage verwirft
und ich hätte am Zielserver keinen Loss.
Das ist Schwachsinn.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, was die meinen.
Aber die Aussage an sich von Vodafone ist Schwachsinn.
Also was damit gemeint ist, muss man sich erstmal angucken, wie Traceroute funktioniert.
Jetzt mal rhetorische Frage.
Wissen alle, wie Traceroute funktioniert?
Ich hoffe nicht, weil dann kann ich es jetzt erklären.
Also es gibt verschiedene Varianten, wie Traceroute funktioniert.
Aber ich erkläre mal die verbreitetste Variante.
Ähm.
Nee, also wenn du unterwegs Paket-Loss hast, dann ist das nicht so.
Das ist nicht so.
Wenn du unterwegs Paket-Loss-Main hast, dann hast du zum Ziel auch auf der gleichen Route Paket-Loss.
Das kann nicht sein, dass ein Paket verloren geht zwischendurch und dann auf einmal beim Ziel wieder ankommt.
Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Ähm.
Was die meinen ist, dass die Server unterwegs schlicht und ergreifend auf deine ICMP-Pakete nicht antworten
und deswegen im Traceroute drinne steht, dass du den, dass du, ähm.
Na, wenn du Traceroute machst, keine Ahnung.
Immer Traceroute.
Dann hast du Server, die halt keine ICMP.
Da muss ich jetzt auch mal kurz zu erklären, wie Traceroute prinzipiell.
Warte mal, wie geht denn.
Warum mache ich.
Was ist eigentlich, was ist eigentlich mit mir kaputt, dass ich das unter Windows mache.
Geh mal fort.
Traceroute.
Was nehmen wir mal schönes.
Äh, äh.
Battlenet.
So, Battlenet.
So, wenn ich da Traceroute mache.
Was auch immer das für krasse Domains sind unterwegs.
Oder Traceroute.
Wie der Cisco-Fan sagt.
Äh.
Da sieht man unterwegs so Dinger hier.
Wenn du so Dinger siehst, heißt das nicht, dass du Packet Lost hast.
Ähm, wenn du so Dinger siehst, heißt das nur, dass das, dass der Server an dieser Stelle nicht auf deine Pakete antwortet, die Traceroute schickt.
Der nächste antwortet wieder.
Äh, Traceroute funktioniert folgendermaßen.
Du hast in einem Paket, hast du einen Setting, das nennt sich TTL.
Das ist so die, die Standard, äh.
Du hast ein Setting in deinem Paket, das nennt sich TTL.
Und was Trace, das steht für Time to Live.
Wenn du dieses, wenn das gesetzt ist.
Und ein Router kriegt das.
Ich meine, jeder, jeder Hop hier unter, auf dem Weg ist, ist quasi ein Router.
Ja, oder hier bei jedem Hop wird ein Paket einmal geroutet.
Also da, das ist meins hier.
Das ist, das ist die, das ist Unity Media, die Unity Media Box bei mir.
Also das ist mein Mikrotik-Router.
Das ist die Unity Media Box.
Das ist irgendwas dahinter von Unity Media, was nicht antwortet.
So, und äh, Traceroute funktioniert folgendermaßen.
Du setzt die Time to Live auf 1.
Dann kriegt das dieser Router.
Und antwortet dir, ey, Time to Live 1.
Ich kann das Paket nicht weiterleiten, weil Time to Live überschritten wurde.
Dann schickt dir dieser Router, schickt dir eine Nachricht zurück.
Und sagt.
Alter, ich hab dein Paket wegwerfen müssen.
So, danach schickt Traceroute das gleiche Paket nochmal mit Time to Live 2.
Jetzt muss der nächste Router in, in der Kette dein Paket wegwerfen, weil Time to Live exited.
Und dann antwortet dir der Router, ey, Alter, ich hab dein Paket weggeworfen.
Und der dritte Router in dem Fall hier.
Also das, ähm, wahrscheinlich die, das erste nach meinem Netz bei Unity Media.
Der sagt, wenn er mein Paket kriegt.
Nichts.
Der verwirft das Paket, weil da drin steht Time to Live 3.
Der verwirft das Paket, aber...
Der antwortet, der sagt mir nicht, dass er es verworfen hat.
Und weil er mir nicht sagt, dass er es verworfen hat, kann ich nicht mehr erkennen, welcher Route das ist.
Diese Sternchen hier bedeuten nicht, dass du Packet-Loss hast.
Das hat damit nichts zu tun.
Die Sternchen bedeuten nur, wir müssen uns mal gucken, wie das Ding unter Windows aussieht.
Ähm.
Bisschen langsamer.
Haha, Sebastian, gute Frage.
Keine Ahnung.
Keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Okay, Windows Traceroute ist ein bisschen langsamer.
Ich glaube, Windows Traceroute macht das auch so, wie ich es erklärt habe.
Ich glaube, das Linux Traceroute macht standardmäßig kein ICMP Time to Live Traceroute.
Ich glaube, das macht irgendeine UDP-Geschichte.
Aber die, das weiß ich, wie ich es erklärt habe, diese ICMP Time to Live-Geschichte,
ist so die Standard-Traceroute-Implementierung, die man auch immer so lernt.
Ja, ja, aorta.net.
Das ist, ähm...
Kein Schimmer.
Ich würde sagen, äh, weil es Frankfurt ist, würde ich sagen, irgendwas vom D6.
Aber die haben, glaube ich, eine andere Domain.
DEFRA04D.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber das hier, das hier, wie gesagt, bedeutet nicht, dass du Pack-and-Loss hast.
Das bedeutet nur, dass dieser Router an dieser Stelle, ähm, nicht antwortet auf deine Pakete von Traceroute.
So, und wie kommst du jetzt da drauf?
Dass du 30% oder, ähm, 30% Pack-and-Loss hast?
Zeigt der das an, oder was?
Muss ich mal gucken.
Was Windows Traceroute am Ende so anzeigt.
Warum hast du die Zeugensuche auf Twitter retweetet?
Hast du damit was zu tun?
Ja, nur weil du was retweetest, musst du natürlich gleich daran beteiligt sein, ne?
Ne, ich rede die Video öfters was von der Polizei in Frankfurt.
Und ich mir denke, ey, vielleicht hat jemand was gesehen.
Pingplotter, okay.
Also, es kann, es kann eigentlich nicht sein,
dass du das nicht retweetest.
Also, es kann, es kann eigentlich nicht sein, dass du das nicht retweetest.
dass du Pack-and-Loss unterwegs hast und am Ziel nicht.
Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Wenn du die gleiche Route verwendest
und du hast Pack-and-Loss auf der Route,
dann kommt dein Paket nicht an.
Also, es ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn zu sagen,
ähm,
es gibt überhaupt keinen Sinn zu sagen,
ja, du verlierst an einem Hopp,
ähm, 30% Pakete,
aber beim Ziel hast du kein Pack-and-Loss.
Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Wenn auf dieser Route irgendwo 30% Pakete hast,
wenn auf dieser Route irgendwo 30% Pakete hast,
hast du auf allen Hopps dahinter
natürlich auch diese 30% Pakete,
weil die Pakete sind ja weg.
Irgendwie logisch, oder?
Also, aber 10% Pakete sind auch ganz schön viel.
Wie kommst du denn überhaupt auf die Idee,
das zu testen?
Hast du irgendwie Probleme in Spielen?
Sind, äh,
245 zu Battle.net ein bisschen hoch?
Doch, irgendwie schon.
Mal gucken, wie weit es mit Ping ist.
Tja, Blizzard ist, äh,
huge langsam gerade.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob Battle.net
ist, aber ich weiß gar nicht, ob es da ist.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es da ist.
Ist Battle.net überhaupt die Blizzard-Geschichte?
Ich meine, das heißt zwar so, aber...
Ach doch, die Seite ist auch übelst langsam.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Blizzard ist langsam.
Ich meine, wir können mal was Schnelleres nehmen, so hier.
Oder, oder hier, ein Wobblords.tv nehmen.
Ah, das ist ordentlich schnell.
Oder 1111 können wir nehmen.
Das ist auch ordentlich, äh,
umschwankend das so eigentlich.
Das ist bestimmt jetzt so ein Unity-Media-Programm.
Wie geht denn, wie geht denn das unter Windows T?
Wie macht man unter Windows
unendlich lang Ping?
Einfach nur Minus T.
Warum sind die Ping-Zeiten,
wenn ich Minus T mache, anders als ohne Minus T?
Okay, jetzt,
was auch immer.
Wahrscheinlich, frag mich nicht.
Ja doch,
irgendwie schwankt ganz schön.
Das könnte auch, das
könnte eine Unity-Media-Geschichte sein.
Kannst du ein Tracer zu Wobblors Punkt?
Tv machen, können wir auch machen.
Ja, das ist schön stabil.
Ja.
Bisschen, das ist okay.
Okay, man, tja, das ist, das ist sehr schwierig zu diagnostizieren, Remote.
Weil, ob, ob du bei dir wirklich Packet-Loss hast, kannst du ja einfach probieren.
Ähm,
du kannst entweder mal bei dir einen Raspberry anstöpseln an deinen Router und zwischen,
zwischen deinem Rechner und dem Raspberry machst du einfach einen, ähm,
IP-Perf,
oder IP-Perf.
Ach, ein Tracer soll ja auf Wobblors machen, okay.
Das kannst du machen.
Äh, oder aber,
du mietest dir mal irgendwie für fünf Minuten einen Server bei DigitalOcean oder irgendwie sowas.
Halt, wo man weiß, dass die auch eine gute Anbindung haben.
Und machst dann mal einen IP-Perf zwischen, ähm,
dir und diesem Server.
Dann wirst du ja sehen, wo das auftritt.
Orta.net, das ist,
das ist schon geiler Domain-Name für Netzwerk-Kram.
Ähm,
warum Cbaro?
Ich find DigitalOcean nicht schlecht.
Das ist super easy zu verwenden.
Draufgehen, äh, Rechner anlegen, anklicken, ähm, benutzen für zehn Minuten und wieder ausmachen.
Und bezahlst da am Ende dann eben 35 Cent oder so.
Das ist halt auch nicht teuer.
Scaleway hab ich noch nicht verwendet.
Ja,
0 Nm geht rüber.
S,
S, 6, 4, 5, 3.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Cbaro, ich hab jetzt irgendwas gesagt, aber es ist nicht teuer.
Wahrscheinlich viel billiger.
Ich weiß nicht, was bei DigitalOcean, Ocean kostet gerade.
Das müsste man auf jeden Fall, Main, das müsste man jetzt ein bisschen genauer analysieren.
Das kann man, äh, kann man jetzt, wie gesagt, Remote schlecht sagen.
Aber wenn du testen willst, ob es wirklich an dir liegt,
dann würde ich einfach an der Kiste,
wo dein Ausgang ist,
ähm,
was anstöpseln und gucken, ob zwischen deinem Desktop und dieser Kiste, ob es da auch Pegalos gibt.
Da kannst du ja schon mal ausschließen, dass es irgendwie an dir liegt.
Aber Vodafone ist auch nicht gerade dafür bekannt, jetzt qualitativ so der beste Anbieter zu sein.
Es, ich weiß, es sind letztendlich alle Anbieter nicht dafür bekannt, alle Anbieter haben genug Probleme.
Aber Vodafone ist von dem, was ich an, äh, was ich von Leuten höre und was ich über, was ich auch an berichten und, ähm,
wenn man das, äh, Bewertungen und User-Erfahrungen angucken kann, nicht oben mit dabei.
Ja.
Habe ich euch eigentlich erzählt, dass ich jetzt meinen Telekom-Anschluss endlich gekündigt habe?
Es hat auch keine, keine halbe Stunde gedauert.
Da hat die Telekom, ähm, Telekom-Kundenrückgewinnungs, ähm, Hotline-Dudes angerufen.
Und, ähm, wollten mir dann erzählen, dass, äh, dass es ja furchtbar schade ist, dass ich
von der Telekom wechseln will und ob ich nicht wüsste, das hat, das hat er wirklich gefragt, ne?
Ob ich nicht wüsste, wer der Premium-Anbieter in Deutschland ist.
Das ist eine bescheuere Frage.
Habe ich gesagt, äh, okay, lasst mich verraten.
Also, sie rufen von der Telekom an, da kann ja der einzige Premium-Anbieter nur die Telekom sein, oder?
Ja, und das kommt nicht von ungefähr, hat er dann gesagt.
Schön, oh Gott, ey.
Das ist ein bescheuerter Grund, ey.
Ob es die Leute an die gekündigt haben und fragen, ob sie nicht wissen, wer der Premium-Anbieter ist.
Weil was, was genau soll ein Premium-Anbieter überhaupt sein?
Selbstdefiniertes Zeug.
Ja, nice, Matrix1337, ich hoffe bei einem gescheiten Laden.
Premium gleich teuer.
Ja, aber Telekom ist jetzt gekündigt.
Ich habe ab, am nächsten Monat, wie viel Kontakt hast du noch mit dem Friseur?
Regelmäßig.
Ähm, ja, ähm, was wollte ich sagen, genau, ich habe jetzt die Telekom ja gekündigt.
Und am nächsten Monat habe ich dann nur noch Unity Media für...
Für Fernseh-Internet.
Und für Telefon habe ich, bin ich, dann habe ich die Rufnummer zu einem VoIP-Anbieter portieren lassen.
Das heißt, ich bin jetzt mit der Ortstelefonnummer komplett unabhängig von irgendwelchen Anbietern.
Das ist eigentlich ganz geil.
Ja, der Friseur, der streamt auch ab und zu mal.
Lass gucken, der spielt aber, der spielt Black Desert, Kreiselcrime.
Kreiselcrime MMO.
Geht eigentlich mit der Musik ab.
Das hört sich sehr unharmonisch an, irgendwie.
Festnetz nochmal in 2K19, ja, ich benutze es ja auch nicht.
Internet in Deutschland sagt...
Ja, ist ja auch so, oder?
Das habe ich, ich weiß, das habe ich schon vor Jahren gesagt in Videos und das sage ich immer noch.
Wie kann in Traceroute eigentlich die Zeiten unterschiedlich sein?
Zum Server direkt 8ms, zu den Routern dazwischen mehr.
Ähm, so...
Bin ich mir jetzt auch nicht so ganz sicher.
Ich denke mal, es liegt daran, weil das hier ja nicht wirklich ein Paket ist, was von A nach B durchgeht,
sondern das ist ein Paket, das ist eins, das, das, das, das, das, das und das hat halt mal 108ms gedauert.
Und man darf nicht vergessen, hier muss der Router ja eine Custom Fehlermeldung für dich generieren
und vielleicht sind die Dinger gerade besonders beansprucht und haben einfach keinen Bock drauf und das ist ganz niedrig priorisiert.
Könnte ja sein.
So, Leute.
Also, ihr habt es ja schon am, am Titel vom Stream jetzt gesehen.
Das ist heute, es gibt kein spezielles Thema.
Das einzige Thema, was ich mir überlegt habe, was wir ausprobieren können, wenn uns nicht genug anderes Zeug zum Schwätzen und Gucken einfällt,
wir können mal WireGuard VPN ausprobieren.
Das habe ich ja schon gesagt, dass ich das mal seit einer Weile ausprobieren will, mal zu installieren unter Linux und zu gucken, wie man das einrichtet.
Das könnten wir machen.
Ich habe hier den, den, den Raspberry noch liegen.
Oder ich habe Theorie zu Gast.
Zwei Raspberries dafür noch liegen.
Auf dem einen könnten wir mal einen WireGuard Server installieren und dann ein VPN hin aufbauen und gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Ansonsten mache ich jetzt mal hier.
Bist du krank?
Ja, bin ich.
Achso, das ist von gestern noch.
Das ist alles von gestern.
Ich glaube, das kann ich alles löschen.
Erstmal zwei Wochen krank schreiben lassen.
Ne, ich war jetzt die Woche krank geschrieben.
Das war diesmal auch echt nötig.
Ich habe, also ich habe selten Erkältung und ich habe selten eine Erkältung, wo ich tatsächlich mal drei Tage gehen muss.
Normalerweise geht es mir eigentlich ganz gut.
Dann lege ich mal einen Tag und dann ist wieder okay.
Ja, das würde ich machen.
Also ich würde erstmal kontrollieren, dass die Netzwerkprobleme auf jeden Fall nicht bei dir lokal liegen.
Ja, du könntest zum Beispiel jetzt mal kurz schreiben, wie das bei dir daheim aufgebaut ist.
Also wenn das so was ganz Simples ist wie dein Desktop Rechner an der Fritzbox und dann direkt ins Internet.
Da kann ja eigentlich nicht allzu viel, allzu viel passieren zwischendurch.
Und ein bisschen Gaming Traffic Routen kriegst.
Gaming Traffic Routen kriegt eine Fritzbox auch hin.
Ich halte die Fritzbox nicht für einen super geilen Router oder für ein tolles Netzwerkgerät an sich.
Aber das kriegt sie hin.
Und die Fritzbox ist ein super Multifunktionsgerät.
Das auf jeden Fall.
Der eigentliche Netzwerk Part kommt halt bei der Fritzbox ein bisschen kurz.
Aber es ist halt auch ein Noob Gerät letztendlich.
Also das in der Fritzbox soll halt jeder verwenden können.
Da haben sie halt noch ein paar Funktionen.
Die normale User nicht so brauchen wie irgendwelche WLANs oder mehrere SSIDs oder so was.
Haben sie halt verzichtet drauf.
Oder halt sehr rudimentär implementiert.
Das ist was für ein Stream.
Okay.
Hehehe.
Das ist ein guter Tweet.
Das ist ein echt guter Tweet.
Mal angenommen wir wollen, dass Windows unsere PCs und Notebooks mit Plotware misshandelt.
Was gehört auf jeden Fall dazu?
Also wenn man Windows wirklich verploten will.
Was auf jeden Fall dazu gehört.
Was auf jeden Fall dazu gehört ist ein Virenscanner.
Ohne Virenscanner kein bloat.
Am besten noch irgendwie Norton Antivirus Internet Security Suite 2019 Premium Edition.
Dann hast du dann erstmal 2 Gigabyte.
Was definitiv McAfee.
Okay.
Ist der Typ nicht im Knast?
Oder war das ein anderer?
War der nicht im Jail?
Ne.
Doch nicht.
Das war ein anderer.
Okay.
Keine Ahnung.
Was auch wichtig ist.
Diese ganzen Pay2Win.
Diese ganzen komischen Spiele.
Die Windows schon standardmäßig installiert.
Hier.
Oder mittlerweile nicht mehr.
Candy Crush und alle zig Games die so ähnlich aussehen.
Dann braucht man noch irgendwelche Tune-Up-Utilities 2019.
Was bräuchte man sonst noch Leute?
Was sagt der Chat?
Register Cleaner.
Ja.
Registry Cleaner.
Eine Register Cleaner muss auch unbedingt drauf.
Office Demo.
Gibt es mittlerweile auch noch eine Office Demo?
Office 300.
Demo.
Das gibt's noch gar nicht mehr.
Doch.
Office 365 Test.
Ach ja.
Das muss auch drauf.
Tune-Up.
Ja.
Tune-up muss sein.
TeamViewer.
Für den Support.
Ja.
Beschneidert Antwort.
Das ist nichts zum installieren.
Ich muss noch ein paar Sachen zeigen haben.
Ich muss mal meine Fragen jetzt echt aufräumen.
Ähm, das funktioniert nicht so ganz, oder?
Ich klicke das unterste an.
Und dann kommt da etwas ganz merkwürdiges.
Ich glaube, mein Tool ist kaputt, oder?
Ich meine, jetzt hier steht ja was USB und hier steht was.
Und jetzt klicke ich das weg.
Und jetzt kommt auf einmal da unten was Neues.
Ich glaube, das ist verbuggt.
17.54 Uhr, jetzt müsste 18.02 Uhr da drin stehen.
Was?
Ich glaube, mein Tool ist nicht so ganz richtig, ja.
Jetzt funktioniert es anscheinend, oder?
Ja, das war irgendwie verbuggt.
Wie wäre es eigentlich mal, wenn du dir eine Grafikkarte programmierst?
Äh.
Nee.
Ich habe letztens ein Video gesehen, wo einer angefangen hat, eine Grafikkarte zu bauen.
Also sehr rudimentär mit VGA.
Das ging 45 Minuten.
Wo er halt die ganzen Schalter...
Die Schaltung zusammengebaut hat für Horizontal- und Vertical-Sync und Zeug, was man halt so braucht.
Und im zweiten Video hat er gesagt, macht er dann die RGB-Ausgabe.
Der RAM-Downloader, ja, den brauchen wir auch noch.
Von Ben Eater, ja, ich glaube, das war der.
Welche Switch-Spiele kannst du empfehlen?
Ich habe nur...
Drei.
Ich habe Mario Kart, ich habe Mario Galaxy und ich...
Ah, nicht Galaxy, Mario Odyssey und Zelda.
Und Zelda.
Sagt hier dir...
Ach, ist es da, wo du deine Ausbildung anfängst?
Nee, habe ich nichts von, sagt mir gar nichts.
Kennst du einen guten, simplen Fax-Server?
Es ist 2019.
Oder Fax?
Kein Schimmer.
Keine Ahnung, wirklich nicht.
Guten Fax-Server.
Ähm.
Warum?
Warum braucht man einen Fax-Server in 2019?
Gut, äh, nee.
Kann ich dir leider keinen empfehlen.
Weiß ich nicht.
Asterisk kann das bestimmt.
Das kann alles.
Aber das ist nicht simpel.
Kein Schimmer, was ein guter Fax-Server ist.
Ein Clear-All-Button.
Ja, ein Clear-All-Button wäre wirklich nicht verkehrt einzubauen, hä?
Ein Clear-All-Button wäre, glaube ich, echt nicht verkehrt einzubauen.
Machen wir den hin.
Machen wir hier am besten einen Clear-All-Button hin.
Oben, hä?
Moment, oben links in die Ecke.
Oh, warte, ey.
Guck mal, ob der...
Ja.
Oben eine Navigationsleiste hin machen, aber brauch ich nicht.
Machen wir da oben jetzt einen Button.
Ja.
Ja, da oben ist jetzt ein Delete-Button fertig.
Eventuell mit Refresh-Button.
Oh, jetzt wird's aber advanced, äh.
Das Ding refresht automatisch, es sei denn, ich stelle es auf Refresh 0.
Ach, ich denke mal, da hab ich gerade irgendwie keinen, keinen Nerv drauf.
Ja, ähm, wie gesagt, ich bin heute ziemlich, äh, planlos, was, äh, was Stream angeht.
Ich hab einfach angemacht.
Ich hab nichts Spezielles vor oder sowas.
Ähm, ihr müsst mir jetzt entweder, entweder machen wir jetzt WireGuard VPN.
Oder ihr müsst mich doch mit irgendwelchen Sachen, äh, zuknallen, wo ich was zu erzählen kann.
Oder zu zeigen kann.
Hab ich irgendwas übersehen vielleicht?
Ach ja, stimmt.
Mario Maker 2 wollte ich mir auch holen.
Ich hab, ich, ich hab eh meine Switch gefühlt, äh, keine Ahnung, wie lange hab ich die angehabt.
Also auf jeden Fall, ich hab meine Switch auf jeden Fall mehr angehabt, als Xbox One und Xbox 360, äh, und Xbox, Xbox One und, und PS4 zusammen.
Die hab ich ja quasi gar nicht angehabt.
Die Switch hatte ich immerhin für Breath of the Wild an.
Wie lange braucht man da so, bis man da halbwegs beim Endgegner ist, wenn man sich die Welt anguckt?
Wahrscheinlich so, ja, 20, 20, 30 Stunden.
Dann Mario, äh, Odyssey nochmal so, würde ich sagen, so 50.
10 Stunden, oder nee, nicht ganz.
10 Stunden, ähm, ich hab ja nicht alle, alle Sterne gemacht, ja.
Oder, äh, Monde, oder, ähm, ja, und Mario Kart auch nicht so lange.
Aber auf jeden Fall würde ich sagen, schon mal so 50, 60 Stunden hatte ich wenigstens die Switch an.
Im Vergleich zu Xbox One und PS4, die hatte ich zusammen vielleicht 5 Stunden an, oder so.
Ist eigentlich voll der Witz, ne?
Wenn man sich das mal überlegt.
Ja, dann, ich würd sagen, wir, wir gucken uns das jetzt einfach mit WireGuard mal an.
Weil WireGuard ist ja so der neueste Schrei, was, was VPN angeht.
Ich hab noch überhaupt nichts mitgemacht.
Warum WireGuard und nicht OpenVPN?
Weil ich, ja, OpenVPN kenn ich schon, WireGuard kenn ich noch nicht.
Es geht einfach darum, dass ich mir das mal angucken kann.
Ich will es nicht verwenden, ich will es mir einfach mal angucken.
Wir könnten uns jetzt natürlich, ne, wir könnten uns jetzt,
irgendwie bei DigitalOcean oder so eine VM machen, zu der wir uns connecten.
Allerdings ist, glaube ich, keine so gute Idee, öffentlich das Ganze zu machen.
Dann habe ich sofort, sofort die Chinesen im VPN.
Meinst du, dass die wenigsten Spiele dich mittlerweile noch flashen,
weil man mittlerweile einfach alles gesehen hat?
Also ich denke, da spielt auf jeden Fall mit rein,
dass man mit vielen Sachen nicht mehr so begeistert werden kann, wie am Anfang.
Ich glaube, das, wo man das am besten verfolgt, ist, dass man sich nicht mehr so begeistert wird,
sondern man sich nicht mehr so begeistert wird, als am Anfang.
Ich glaube, das, wo man das am besten verfolgt, ist, dass man sich nicht mehr so begeistert wird, als am Anfang.
schönsten sieht, ist, wenn man mal eine Call of Duty
Singleplayer-Kampagne spielt.
Call of Duty 4, 5,
MW2, Black Ops 1
hat mich voll
gefesselt, die Singleplayer-Kampagne.
Obwohl es im Prinzip der gleiche
lineare Blödsinn ist,
wie die anderen Spiele auch.
Aber irgendwann
habe ich überhaupt keinen Spaß mehr dran gehabt
und ich glaube gar nicht mal, weil es so viel schlechter
war, die CD-Kampagnen danach,
sondern weil es wirklich immer
mehr vom Gleichen ist.
So ein 50. Mal irgendein Heli abschießen,
wo der Raketenwerfer davor gesport ist
und sowas. Also ich denke, das spielt schon
mit rein.
Aber ich glaube, das hauptsächliche Problem ist
einfach, dass es
den Spielen zum größten Teil irgendwie an
Substanz fehlt.
Zumindest die großen Titel.
Wo man auch gar keinen Bock hat,
sich irgendwie großartig noch einzuarbeiten.
Hat man
mit WireGuard auch den Ping of Glory
von der Telekom?
Was zum Teufel ist der Ping of Glory?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Hallo?
Zugucker?
Das Problem ist, dass wir alt werden.
Ich glaube,
das liegt gar nicht mal so sehr da dran.
Kennst du das
Twitter-Ad nicht? Ne.
Ping of Glory von der was?
Da komme ich jetzt wahrscheinlich bei irgendeiner
Porn-Seite raus.
Ping of Glory.
Was zum Teufel ist mit der Telekom los?
Okay, Moment.
Wie siehst du Pro-Gamers?
Sichert euch den Ping of Glory
für eure Pro-Gamer-Karriere jetzt ab.
Ah, Telekom.
Was die Gesellschaft denkt,
was meine Freunde denken,
wie ich mich fühle, was ich wirklich mache.
Das ist auch noch schlecht gemimt.
Das ist auch noch nicht mal gut.
Oh Mann.
Gerne verlegt uns die Glasfaser.
Es ist eh übelster Cringe teilweise,
wenn man sich das anguckt.
Wo habe ich eigentlich mein Raspberry rumfliegen?
Es ist eh übelster Cringe, wenn man sich das anguckt.
Teilweise die Werbung auf YouTube von manchen Firmen
oder manche Tweets oder auf Twitter.
Irgendwelche
Ads,
wo irgendwelche Firmen versuchen,
so im Trend
der Zeit zu sein.
Es gibt ganz wenige Anzeigen,
wo ich mir denke,
ihr habt das Internet so ungefähr
halbwegs gut
nachgemacht.
Die meisten Sachen wirken einfach so übelst cringe so.
Wo du denkst, da saß irgendein Marketingtyp drinnen,
der hat sich 300 Meme-Bildchen angeguckt
und hat versucht, was draus zu stricken,
was irgendwie auf sie passt und lustig ist,
ohne den eigentlichen Sinn
dahinter verstanden zu haben.
Also, ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Man kann ja nicht wirklich von Sinn sprechen,
aber ohne so die Gedanken dahinter verstanden zu haben
und dann ist das echt...
Das ist so, wie wenn du in irgendwelchen Fernsehsendungen
früher so Jugendsprache gesehen hast,
die irgendwie 10 Jahre zuvor war.
Oh, das ist aber voll krass, Alter.
Oder irgendwie sowas.
Das sagt doch keine Sau mehr.
Wahrscheinlich ist Bruder muss los
noch nicht mal mehr angesagt heute.
Wahrscheinlich sagst du heute wieder,
aber das kriegst du ja nur so richtig mit,
wenn du da auch dabei bist.
Und dementsprechend wirkt das auch immer
so ultra cringe,
wenn das irgendwelche Marketingläden versuchen.
Voll krass, genau.
Das hat man vor
vor 35,
vor 40,
20, 30 Jahren hat man das gesagt.
Heute fährst du Pedalo.
Ne, wie heißen die Dinger?
Heißen die nicht so?
Pedalo?
Ah, genau.
Okay, äh, mein Raspberry, wo ist er denn?
Ja, ähm, komm mal her.
Raspberry, komm mal her.
Nicht den anderen Scheiß runterspeisen.
Ich hab den hier sehr abenteuerlich platziert.
Ich muss nämlich meinen Raspberry holen
und die SD-Karte rausmachen.
SD-Karte?
Kartenleser?
Wir machen da nämlich ein neues Raspbian drauf,
weil der Kram hat mittlerweile
so viele Updates gekriegt,
seitdem wir das das letzte Mal gemacht haben.
Wahrscheinlich sind wir mit einer neuen Installation
besser dran.
Ist das Halo?
Ne, fängt an wie Halo, oder?
Ja, jetzt nicht mehr.
Warte mal.
Das muss jetzt einmal sein.
Zu leise.
Was ist das für ein...
Das ist ja...
richtige 2000 2001er bildformat passende musikuntermalung für raspion download
so wir brauchen buster light moment das war es gerade gelöscht habe ist das ist
das gleiche wie was zum download gibt fail da kann ich jetzt mal was cooles
zeigen ich habe das ja gerade gelöscht hier
und normalerweise ist es weg aber ich habe ein rm gealiast auf auf einen
papierkorb das kann ich einfach sagen trash restore file nummer null und zack
da ist es wieder das ist mal pock oder quasi der
kommandozeilen papierkorb das ist massive big brain 900 iq plays gut wenn
sich da nichts geupdatet hat dann brauchen wir auch in raspion nicht neu
zu installieren sondern können einfach den raspberry mal direkt ans
netzwerkkabel und den strom packen
ich schmeiße ich habe ich habe ja neben mir die zwei rechner stehen der
spielerechner und den den anderen netz forscher streaming rechner und ich habe
da mittlerweile so viele kartons und dinger und zeug drauf jetzt muss ich
aufpassen dass ich nicht alles runter schmeißen wenn ich den raspberry darunter raus ziehe
so clips und nun brauchen wir chromversorgung für das ding ob wir den einfach an usb vom rechner anschließen sollten
ach nee wir packen das ding braucht er wieder usb ich habe gar kein usb cda moment
wo habe ich wo habe ich den usb zu scheiße meine china kabel sind noch nicht da hatte
ich hatte mir denn ich hatte mir doch hier die usb kabel bestellt ich habe ja
ich habe andere bestellt als die wir uns im stream angeguckt haben ich habe
bestellt in one wartet mal ich zeige euch mal
ja allerdings 50 stück
ich glaube da stand einfach drin viel noch ja im prinzip mehr oder weniger die
hier bloß 50 bloß 50 keine keine 100 also hier die die micro usb auf usb c
übrigens die bilder sind immer übelst schlecht freigestellt in dem fall geht's
wann kommt half life 3 nach episode 3
die halo 3 also die halo musik an sich ist wirklich ziemlich nice
Wieso brauchst du so viele?
Ich brauche eigentlich nicht so viele.
Ich habe bloß keinen Bock, immer USB-Kabel zu suchen.
Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, ich bestelle mir jetzt einfach mal 50 USB-Kabel, dann ist Ruhe.
Weil jetzt habe ich ja gerade wieder das Problem, wo habe ich denn USB-C-Kabel?
Wo habe ich denn USB-C-Kabel?
Das ist echt...
Ich habe nicht viele USB-C-Kabel.
Ich habe welche, aber ich weiß nicht, warum.
USB-C.
Wo habe ich denn USB-C-Kabel?
Ja.
Ich brauche ein USB-C-Kabel, sonst kann ich den Raspberry Pi 4 nicht anschließen.
Warte mal kurz, ich gucke mal in meine USB-Kiste, ob da was drin ist.
Das ist alles Micro-USB.
Wo habe ich denn hier ein USB-C-Kabel?
Das ist jetzt ja voll...
Hier wieder super, super nice Vorbereitung.
Ich weiß...
Wo habe ich denn hier ein USB-C-Kabel?
Ah.
Ha!
Ich habe es!
Da ist es!
Trash-Sealer.
Ja, das ist wirklich praktisch.
Ich habe es gefunden.
Pock!
So.
Angestöpselt ist es.
Dann schließen wir den Raspberry mal an.
Diddlid, diddlid.
Hopp.
Ups, der ist falsch rum.
Mal richtig rum.
Achtung.
So.
Er ist dran.
Und leuchtet.
Ah, dann sollte das auch funktionieren.
Sollen wir mal wieder die Anhörmusik...
Sehr schön.
Dann connecten wir uns da mal per SSH drauf auf das Ding.
Ich hoffe mal, das kriegt die gleiche IP wie das letzte Mal.
Wenn nicht, muss ich in den Router gucken, was der...
Der CP, dem Ding...
Ah, da ist er doch.
Ich glaube, ich hatte auch keinen Custom-Name gegeben.
Das passt schon.
Und wir machen erstmal ein Update.
Da dürfte es ja ein paar...
Paar Updates gegeben haben jetzt für das Ding.
Ne Booster.
Ja, ich hab nen iPhone, das...
Was?
Lightning?
Ja, ja, Lightning.
Äh, was?
Das hab ich noch nie gesehen.
Was?
Was möchte mir das jetzt sagen?
Changed its suit from...
From testing to stable...
Ach so!
Ja, ja, ja, ist gut.
Ist doch okay, dass es jetzt stable ist.
Da hab ich auch keine Schmerzen mit.
Erwartet auf ein Jahr.
Ja, einfach immer Ja drücken.
Wir waren mal bei einem China-Laden.
Und wir haben die Bedienung absolut nicht verstanden.
Also in Frankfurt gibt es ja jede Menge China-Läden, ne?
Und wir haben es wirklich nicht gecheckt.
Und auf einmal sagt die Bedienung so auf ganz schlechtem Deutsch...
Einfach sagen Ja.
Oder einfach immer sagen Ja.
So nach dem Motto...
Wir sollen gar nicht mit ihr lange diskutieren, sondern wenn sie was sagt, sollen wir einfach sagen Ja.
Und das machen wir seitdem auch immer, wenn wir in den Laden reingehen.
Und man muss sagen, das funktioniert wirklich gut.
Man...
Das ist so Default...
Default-Accept einfach.
Äh...
Micharo, das USB-C-Kabel ist wirklich ein Problem, weil das ist so...
Noch nicht so extrem verbreitet, dass man davon so viel rumfliegen hat wie Micro-USB.
Aber dafür wird es in Zukunft ordentlich verbreitet sein.
Und ich hab jetzt ja vorgesorgt, wenn die Chinesen endlich liefern...
Ähm...
Ich hab mir nämlich 50 Micro-USB-Kabel mit USB-C-Adapter gekauft.
Dann ist endlich ein für alle Mal USB...
USB-Knappheit erledigt.
Und wenn man sich das mal anschaut, das ist eigentlich übelst billig, ne?
Und es gibt...
Die gibt es übrigens noch günstiger.
Das ist einer der bisschen teureren Anbieter.
Aber ich...
Wenn man sich das jetzt mal überlegt...
Das sind 100 USB-Kabel mit Adapter inklusive Versand mit DHL für 85 Euro.
Das sind...
Das sind quasi 75 Cent...
Äh...
85 Cent für das USB-Kabel.
Also jetzt bei 100, ne?
Das ist...
Also dafür kannst du gar keine supergeile Qualität kriegen.
Aber macht nix.
Solange die Dinger...
Geräte mit Strom versorgen ist okay.
Ich...
Genau.
Wir dropshippen die einfach zu...
Zu Leuten, ja.
Aber das sind nicht genau die, die ich mir geholt hab.
100 Stück?
Ne, das sind andere.
Ich bin...
Ich guck mal grad im zweiten Rechner in meine Mails, weil...
Ich zeig euch mal, welche das sind.
Und wenn...
Und wenn die ankommen, dann probieren wir die auch mal aus, ob das funktioniert.
Hier, AliExpress.
AliExpress.
Your order has been shipped.
Am 9.7.
Also die sind schon ein bisschen...
Dear Max, bla bla bla.
Your order has been shipped.
Ja, und wo steht, was ich geordert hab?
Man, was?
200 Pieces?
Ne, Moment.
What the fuck?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ich hab keine 200 Pieces bestellt.
Ich hab damit kein Problem, wenn die Chinesen mir jetzt 200 schicken, aber...
Ich hab...
Ich hab doch keine 200 Stück bestellt.
Moment.
Das muss ich jetzt grad mal überprüfen.
Wo ist meine AliExpress...
Wo ist meine AliExpress-Bestätigung?
Message vom AliExpress.
Bla.
Wo ist meine Auftragsbestätigung?
AliExpress.
Sie wollen 200?
Max sagt ja.
Ja.
Ich hab keine...
Ich hab nur ne Message.
Your order has been shipped.
Und zwar...
Alter, Thunderbird kann die...
Kann die...
Kann die China Mail nicht richtig anzeigen.
Ich hoff...
Ich hab keine 200 bestellt, da bin ich mir ganz sicher.
Ach, scheiß drauf.
Egal.
Ich hab keine 200 bestellt, ich weiß genau, dass ich 50 bestellt hab.
weil 200 war wirklich ein bisschen viel
und ich hab's halt nur
ey, die können mir ruhig 200 schicken, wenn's
auch nur 53 Euro kostet
so, oder
fertig geupdatet
upgrade, muss man
das hier eigentlich noch machen, nee, ich glaub das geht
mittlerweile alles in einem, ne
wird eigentlich, normalerweise wird das hier
ja nicht empfohlen, wird das bei einem 4er noch
empfohlen, soll man das bei einem 4er machen, weiß das jemand
gab's da irgendwelche Patches, dass man
dass man den 4er mal
updaten soll, hier auf Firmware und alles
normalerweise soll man davon ja die Finger
weglassen
ja, also warm wurde das Ding ja als wir's getestet
haben, ordentlich
okay, was für komische Artikel
ich glaub wir upgraden einfach mal nicht
wir lassen das Ding jetzt so, ich mein für
Wireguard ist ja nur wirklich geil
paar Ding, ne
okay, ähm
wie funktioniert das jetzt, äh
Wireguard
Raspbian
der Bachmann-Laden, Alter
hat hier
Raspberry Pi Wireguard
das ist sogar ein halbwegs aktueller
Artikel
ja, Stickstoffkühlung
von Raspberry, ich mein ich hab hier aktuell
ja so einen, so einen, so einen ganz normalen
Passivkühler drauf und das Ding ist jetzt
einfach nur an und ich leg mal die Hand drauf
und das, das ist schon so warm
der macht nix, der eidelt einfach
nur rum, ne,
ähm, man sieht's hier, das Ding macht
nichts
außer eidelt sein
das ist schon so warm, dass du den Finger nicht
drauf liegen lassen kannst
ich soll das bei Klimaanlage Durchzug anmachen
also nicht Klimaanlage an, sondern einfach nur den
die Belüftung anmachen
oh, die Katze guckt
die Katze guckt kritisch vom Schrank jetzt auf die Klimaanlage
Chico, nichts Schlimmes, ne
nichts Schlimmes
oh, die Katze ist kritisch
mit der Klimaanlage
die guckt nicht so erfreut
die Gür ist nichts Schlimmes
oh je, jetzt hab ich sie, jetzt hab ich sie ver, jetzt hab ich sie verwirrt, ja
okay, alles aufbauen, zähl ab, Raspberry Pi
blablabla
ähm, VPN-Netz, okay, Clients, also Road Warrior
ähm, ne, wir, wir machen die Verbindung, machen wir dann vom, äh
gut, ok, wir brauchen auf jeden Fall noch ein zweites Netz
für das VPN, sonst funktioniert's nicht richtig
wie krieg ich Maus?
Support mit I3 hin?
Hä?
Maus anschließen?
Das ist von Haus aus. Also da musst du
nichts machen.
Wenn der X-Solver deine Maus erkennt, ist gut.
Dann geht das einfach.
Wann machst du das mit den Subs?
Vielleicht mache ich es direkt nach dem Stream heute.
Okay, Wireguard
Installation auf dem Raspberry Pi.
Gibt es denn ab
Search Wireguard? Gibt es das denn schon
vielleicht mittlerweile in den Repos drinnen?
Nein.
Komm, man hat sogar eine Anleitung für Buster.
Lan, Alter. Der ist
aber schon ganz schön aktuell.
Erstmal Kernel Headers installieren.
Kernel Headers, bam.
Kann nie schaden. Wahrscheinlich muss er Zeug
kompilieren.
Ja, ja, I3 hat immer Maus Support. Also brauchst du gar nichts.
Wenn der X-Solver deine Maus erkennt, dann ist gut.
Macht der hier jetzt? Moment.
Ach, macht er da?
Der aktiviert das Debian Unstable
Repo und dann
addet er Keys von Ubuntu.
Ich weiß nicht genau, was er da macht,
ehrlich gesagt.
Aber er addet neue Repos,
addet neue
Keys, wo wahrscheinlich
Pakete signiert sind.
Dann stellt er ab irgendwie so ein,
dass die Pakete irgendwie keine
Priorität haben oder sowas.
Das sieht mir unnötig kompliziert aus.
Gibt es nicht einfach ein
ordentliches
Depot mit Wireguard drinnen?
Ach, stimmt.
Stimmt, sorry, nicht Ubuntu.
Ich kann es gar nicht mehr ausschicken.
Ubuntu.
Ubuntu, genau.
Okay.
Ey, wenn die...
Okay, wenn die offizielle
Debian Paket...
Also wenn die offizielle Debian Anleitung
schon sagt, man soll das machen,
dann machen wir das auch.
Wir machen einfach mal,
was der Dude hier treibt. Ich meine, das ist ja nicht schlimm,
wenn es kaputt geht. Wir können den Raspberry einfach
neu installieren und gut ist.
So, Key...
Warum muss ich den Ubuntu-Key enden nochmal?
Das lasse ich mal weg.
Und warum soll ich den Ubuntu-Key enden?
Das ergibt doch überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Vielleicht kommt er später.
Wir machen es auch nicht, wie er das schreibt,
sondern wir machen das so, wie die Debian-Leute das schreiben.
Update.
Okay.
Ja.
Man muss das doch machen.
Da will wohl einer dazu kommen.
Ich will einfach mal Wirecard...
Wirecard?
Wir müssen dem Ding aber wirklich ein eigenes Netz geben.
Mal gucken, wie das funktioniert.
Ja, das stimmt.
Das ist aber echt so.
Ich denke mir bei vielen Tutorials immer so,
ach nee, was die da schreiben, kann überhaupt nicht sein.
Und am Ende stelle ich dann fest,
ach nee, es hätte doch so sein müssen.
So, mal gucken, ob der jetzt auch so...
Okay.
Er will nicht upgraden.
Das ist schon mal gut.
AppInstall Wirecard.
Wire...
Wireguard.
Ähm.
Yes.
Oh, yes.
Kennt noch einer, äh, wie ist das?
Ahmed.
Ahmed the Dead Terrorist.
Das war mal vor so ein paar Jahren,
das ist so ein Bauchredner-Typ.
Hat das angesagt.
Das fand ich übelst lustig damals.
Die Neuauflagen davon, die er gebracht hat,
waren nicht mehr so witzig.
Ähm, aber die ersten...
Der erste, also das Original und, ähm...
Die...
Das erste Weihnachtsspecial fand ich übelst lustig.
Silence, genau.
Richtig.
Oh, SiriusMaxx, was hat er denn geschrieben?
Ich hab's jetzt gar nicht gesehen.
The Gay Lover.
Hat er Pornlinks gespammt, oder was, bei dem Namen?
Erstmal, RIP.
Okay, wir müssen keine Module bauen, wie's aussieht.
Cheats haben wir.
Ich hab's überhaupt nicht gesehen, dass ich...
Also ich hab jetzt auch nichts Schlimmes im Chat gesehen, ehrlich gesagt, aber ich...
vertraue da mal meinen Mods, soweit...
dass, äh, ich sehe auch nicht alles.
Do you know the way.
Das fand ich nie lustig, ich weiß gar nicht, warum das...
warum diese Uganda-Knuckles-Geschichte so abgegangen ist.
Ich fand Uganda-Knuckles übelst unlustig.
Genauso wie Wie-Fan-Zulul oder wie jeder Typ heißt.
Aber auch, da sieht man mal wieder auch, dass nicht jeder Twitch-Humor was für mich ist.
Kennst du Who Killed Captain Alex? Nee.
Tja, Raspberries sind immer wahnsinnig schnell, wenn's um sowas geht.
Wir gucken mal, wir gucken mal, wie...
wie sehr die C...
Achso!
Wollt grad sagen, wie sehr die CPU ausgelastet ist, aber anscheinend hat sich schon erledigt.
Ähm...
Lass' wir mal hier neben so'n Top laufen, oder?
Fahren wir hier oben weiter.
Microsoft-Progressbar.
Okay, Insta-Wire-Reboot.
Okay, Reboot wegen Kernel-Module.
Allerdings könnte man... könnte man eigentlich...
Könnte man... könnte man eigentlich auch, ähm...
Wir rebooten. Wir rebooten sogar.
Ist immerhin die Zeit, haben wir ja.
Tastatur-Tapping ASMR hier.
So, er ist neu gestartet.
Was ich ja, wo wir grade bei... bei Sachen sind, die ich nicht lustig fand, ne?
Ähm, Sachen, die ich übelst lustig fand und die nie so groß rausgekommen sind,
aber die waren... die waren einfach ihrer Zeit voraus,
sind... sind die Videos von Mega64.
Die sind SO lustig, die Zeit.
Wie gesagt, die... die Videos.
Ähm, also nicht alle, sondern die, wo sie die... wo sie die Games nachmachen.
Die sind so lustig.
Aber die waren einfach ihrer... die waren ihrer Zeit voraus, ja?
Die gab's schon zu Zeiten, wo's YouTube noch nicht... noch nicht gab.
Moment.
Oh, haben die... haben die ne Playlist?
Ne, mir... was... was richtig ist?
Resident Evil 4, genau.
Wartet mal.
Das ist...
Das ist übelst lustig gewesen.
Now...
Von 13. Ja, der sagt, das ist übelst alt.
Das ist... das ist mega lustig, aber das Problem ist, die waren ihrer Zeit voraus.
Hätten die das heute, würden die heute die Videos machen, die hätten 5 Millionen Abos.
Now loading Resident Evil 4.
Mehr Auflösung geht nicht.
Resident Evil 4.
Welcome.
What are you buying?
What are you selling?
Come back anytime.
Greetings, stranger.
What are you buying?
Thank you.
Got a lot of good things on sale, stranger.
Here you go.
Thanks.
Welcome.
Hello.
Welcome, are you buying dari te pizza?
Welcome.
What are you selling?
Nothing over here.
Are you picking up the pizza?
Yes.
I'll buy it at a high price.
What's the name?
Stranger.
I'll buy it at a high price.
Ein Bug was ist nicht richtig.
Danke!
Komm schon...
Was kaufst du?
Was verkaufst du?
Nichts.
Du hast das gleich gemacht.
Was kaufst du?
Das ist so kaputt, ey.
Soll ich hier noch sitzen oder gehen wir irgendwo hin?
Ich finde, die haben
sauviele Videos in dieser Richtung.
Ich fände das übelst lustig, ja.
Die waren einfach ihrer Zeit voraus.
Die waren ihrer Zeit voraus, ja.
Würden die das heute machen?
Die hätten 5 Millionen Abos.
Die haben auch noch andere übelst lustige...
Die haben Assassin's Creed noch,
was auch übelst nice ist.
Aber es ist echt...
Ich finde das...
Die hatten damals...
Na?
Wie heißt der? Miyamoto hatten sie mal dabei
in einem Video. Aber es ist halt auch uralt, ja.
Kojima hatten sie
in einem Video mal mit dabei.
Es war alles noch vor YouTube, ja.
Das fand ich halt
übelst lustig. Und die waren zu früh.
Die waren zu früh.
Würden sie heute solche Videos machen,
wäre das übelst...
Würde das übelst abgehen.
Ups. Ähm...
Ja.
Und vor allem hätte es ein bisschen
höhere Quali.
Ach nee, wir haben den Kram schon installiert.
Okay, äh, LS Mod.
Guck mal, ob da irgendwas mit Wireguard...
Sollte da jetzt nicht was
von Wireguard drin stehen?
Ah, nicht. Äh.
Nee, LS Mod schon richtig.
Okay.
Steht nicht drin.
Ist jetzt gut.
Gut oder schlecht.
Werden wir gleich sehen.
Ähm...
Kannst du was über endliche Zustandsmaschinen
erzählen?
Nein, kann ich nicht.
Das ist zu viel Theorie jetzt.
Die haben halt auch Tetris gemacht.
Die haben sau viel in der...
Assassin's Creed ist auch übelst lustig von denen.
Wo sie über so einen Markt
laufen und sich versuchen zu verstecken.
Und so.
Den Pi neu starten.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Muss man nicht neu starten.
Man kann doch einfach sagen, System...
Nee, Sys, Sys...
Oh, nee, wie war es?
Sysctl-p?
Genau, fertig.
Müssen die neu starten.
Ich kann, äh, äh, Moon Itabaku,
ich kann solche theoretischen Sachen
aus dem Handgelenk jetzt nicht rausschütteln.
Keine Ahnung.
Kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Okay, wie funktioniert das jetzt weiter?
Ist die Musik an?
Oder ist die einfach nur leise?
Nur leise.
Äh, weiß jemand, bei welchem VM-Tool
man diese Menüleisten deaktivieren kann?
Oder brauche ich dann die Paid-Version?
Kannst du die hier?
Einfach, äh, was du machen kannst,
du kannst Exclusive-Mode machen,
dann kommt die Leiste nicht mehr.
Wie hieß das Video nochmal?
Aber so war Mega64.
Da gibt es so Playlists, wo sie alle ihre
Social Experiments, oder wie das heißt,
drin haben.
Die Erstellung der Keys wird im Verzeichen
EC-Wireguard durchgeführt, um sicherzustellen,
dass alle deine richtigen Berechtigungen setzen.
You must auf 077.
Äh, das lassen wir mal.
Ich mache meine Keys doch nicht auf 07.
Ach, Moment, das ist Youmars, das ist umgedreht, ne?
Das bedeutet, es kriegt 700.
Geht das bei Workstation-Player
auch wahrscheinlich?
Gehe ich jetzt einfach mal
von aus?
Okay, Keys generieren.
WG, Gen-Key,
WG, Private Key.
Hier machen wir das mal.
Also WG ist wahrscheinlich
das Kommando für Wireguard.
Äh, Keys generieren.
Dann pipen nach T.
T splittet das auf
in die Datei und
also T sorgt dafür, dass das, was
dann an Text quasi in das
in den Befehl reinpipst,
wird einmal in die Datei umgeleitet
und einmal Standard aus wieder rausgeschrieben.
Und danach macht er das
PubKey, okay, der erstellt zwei Key-Files.
Server Public Key und Server Private Key.
War's das jetzt schon?
Hey, easy.
Ähm, okay.
Wahrscheinlich brauchen die dann 708.
0, 0 als Keys.
Alle Key-Files brauchen in der Regel
zumindest mal 0, 0 bei Group und, und Others.
Magst du Singleton?
Ähm, nur Whisky, äh, Klassen eher nicht.
Client Keys generieren.
Moment, das muss ich auf meinem Client jetzt machen.
Nee, Moment.
Ach nee, ah, nee, nee.
Das sind die Keys, die ich für zukünftige Clients generiere,
wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Okay.
Soll man das jetzt auch in dem Verzeichnis machen?
Ähm, Client 1 PubKey.
Ähm, Server Configuration.
Dazu wird die Datei etc. WireGuard WG0 angelegt.
Warum muss es denn WG0 sein?
Ach, das Interface heißt wahrscheinlich später WG0.
Okay, wir copy-pasten das jetzt einfach mal.
IP-Tables, wir machen überhaupt kein IP-Tables.
Wozu sollen wir IP-Tables-Regeln machen?
Wir lassen einfach alles offen.
Ach, da sind IP-Tables-Regeln.
Das, äh, brauchen wir nicht.
Private Key.
Ähm, hinzufügen.
Einen zweiten Client haben wir noch nicht.
Wir haben nur Client 1.
Client 1 ist der Stop-PC.
So.
Client 1 Public Key hinzufügen.
Soll ich da den...
Soll man da jetzt das File hinzufügen?
Oder soll man den Key hinzufügen?
Äh, was wird versucht?
Ich versuche...
Ich probiere gerade WireGuard zu installieren und zu schauen, ähm,
warum alle WireGuard so geil finden.
Ähm, benutzt du noch HDDs in deinem System?
Ja.
Für, wenn man viel Speicher braucht.
Ja, was muss man da jetzt machen?
Client Public Key hinzufügen.
Also, ich vermute mal, dass man hier wirklich jetzt den...
den Key hinzufügen muss.
Und dort den Private Key vom Server.
Aber das im Klartext in eine Config zu schreiben, ist doch irgendwie...
Irgendwie wir.
Warum macht man nicht einfach das Key-File dahin?
Oder?
Da muss da wirklich...
Oder muss...
Nee, da muss das File hin.
Client 1 Punkt...
Wie hab ich...
Wie heißt der Kram?
Client 1 Public Key.
Das muss...
Das muss dahin.
Alles andere wäre total beknackt.
So, Server Private Key.
So.
Okay.
Server Konfiguration.
Bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla.
Client Konfiguration.
Für jeden Client erstelle ich eine Config-Datei.
Client 1 Config.
Hä?
Der hat das doch hier oben schon erstellt.
Warum erstellt er das hier unten dann noch einmal?
Kann man das jetzt verstehen?
Ich überspringe das erst mal.
WireGuard starten.
WG QuickUp WG 0.
Okay, gucken wir mal, ob das überhaupt starten würde.
Äh...
Key is not correct length or format.
Server Private Key.
Okay, dann muss man da wirklich den Key eintragen.
Sehe ich das richtig, ja?
Also, er muss da wirklich...
Okay.
Tragen wir mal da den Key ein.
Jetzt erst mal hier, Leute.
Gleich mal, gleich mal Server Key liegt.
Server Key liegt.
Warum muss man das da im Klartext reinschreiben?
Das ist doch ganz, ganz merkwürdig.
Wozu?
Okay, das war es anscheinend.
So, jetzt läuft WireGuard.
WG.
Ach, da können wir auch mal hier bei Mod WG suchen.
Äh...
Okay, jetzt läuft der, jetzt läuft der Kram anscheinend.
Das heißt, wir haben jetzt hier auch einen Port-Order.
Offen.
Der...
Der da.
Der WireGuard-Port.
51820.
Ja, das ist der WireGuard-Port.
Okay.
Gut, die Config war jetzt relativ simpel.
Ich verstehe zwar immer noch nicht, warum man die Keys im Klartext reinschreiben muss und nicht die Files.
Aber gut.
Ja, warum nicht?
So, ähm...
WireGuard-Status einfach WG.
Okay.
Okay, also wenn ich das richtig sehe, ist unsere IP-Range für...
Genau, unser Netz für WireGuard-VPN ist 10.10.10.
1.
Also quasi 1 bis 254.
Import.
Das heißt, wenn ich das jetzt auf meinem Client installiere...
Können wir mal machen hier, WireGuard.
Die Krams installieren.
Wobei, mal gucken, ob man noch im Server was anderes machen muss.
Firewall-Config lassen wir mal komplett außen vor.
Der offizielle Android-Client.
Windows.
Ey, komm, wir probieren den Windows-Client aus.
Das ist die...
Wenn der Windows-Client funktioniert, funktionieren alle anderen Clients wahrscheinlich auch.
Alles gut, ja.
Wie es geht mit dem Friseur geht es gut.
Mach mal Ausrufezeichen...
Mach mal Ausrufezeichen Friseur.
Ähm...
Dann findest du den Stream von Fabian.
Du bist aber mutig.
Nee, ich mach das in der Windows-VM.
In der Windows-VM installieren wir das jetzt.
Dafür haben wir doch die 3, 3, 30 Milliarden VMs.
Ist das der falsche Befehl?
She baited.
Nee, wisst ihr, wie ist der...
Der ist doch...
Oder...
Ausrufe...
Mach mal Ausrufezeichen Fabian.
Ausrufezeichen...
Das haben wir doch als Befehl drin, ne?
Ah, Ausrufezeichen Fabian ist das.
Okay.
Okay, gibt's das schon im Windows-Store, WireGuard?
Wire...
Guard.
Was zum Teufel hat der Scheiß mit WireGuard zu tun?
A guy to become...
Coming a...
Photoshop Wizard.
Klingt voll nach WireGuard.
She baited.
She, she, she, she baited.
Okay, Windows-Client.
Wo ist der Windows-Client?
Windows-Client.
Ah.
WireGuard.com install.
Windows.
She, she, she baited.
Äh, was muss man dann machen?
Import Tunnel Files.
Ah, die Client-Config muss ich dann importieren.
Aha.
Machen wir.
Dann erzeugen wir jetzt mal die Client-Config, würde ich sagen.
Weil die Client-Config haben wir, soweit ich das jetzt gesehen habe,
haben wir die noch gar nicht erzeugt.
Ähm...
Hier, Client-Config.
Ach, das ist...
Deswegen muss man das doppelt machen.
Das ist die Server-Config und das ist nicht die Config,
die der Server braucht für den Client.
Das ist die Config, die man später auf dem Client einbaut.
Fügt.
Ah, so.
Easy as a fuck.
Würde ich das sagen.
So, Client-Config.
Zack.
Copy-Paste.
Endpoint.
Was...
Was hat man in Raspberry für eine IP?
Geh weg.
Ähm.
Ups.
Ich hätte es vielleicht mal...
Mal speichern sollen.
Ähm, was hat man...
Was hat man in Raspberry für eine IP?
Ja.
Was soll das überhaupt werden, wenn es fertig ist?
Äh, ein WireGuard-VPN.
Ein WireGuard-VPN.
Und ich versuche rauszukriegen, warum alle WireGuard-VPN so geil finden.
Endpoint.
Ja, hier.
So, das da.
Alle IPs.
Naja, das ist ziemlich doppelt gemoppelt, oder?
Ich meine, ich muss nicht...
Ich muss nicht alle IPs eintragen und eine einzelne IP.
Das ist...
Das ist ziemlich, ziemlich doppelt, ne?
Äh, Server-Public-Key hinzufügen.
Server-Public-Key...
Ist der da?
WireGuard-VPN.
Habe ich noch nichts mitgemacht bisher.
Client-One-Private-Key hinzufügen.
Ich finde es ein bisschen merkwürdig, dass die so viel mit...
Mit, ähm...
Keys in Config-Files hantieren, anstatt einfach ein Config-File und ein Key-File zu nehmen, was man zusammen in Zip packt oder so.
DNS.
Nein, nein.
DNS ist, äh...
Google.
Wenn schon.
Ne, DNS nehmen wir mal meinen internen.
Mein interner ist, äh...
Nicht, dass ich das Mist erzähle.
Ich glaube, der...
Ähm...
Okay, das heißt doch jetzt, diese Datei brauche ich auf Windows.
Diese Datei brauche ich auf meinem Windows.
Und importiere es in den Windows-WireGuard-Client.
Und dann sollte alles funktionieren.
Und wenn das wirklich alles ist, was man machen muss, dann kann ich verstehen, dass die Leute WireGuard-VPN so nice finden.
Weil das ist im Vergleich zu OpenVPN ja nun wirklich der Witz, ne, ans Setup.
Machen wir trotzdem.
Okay.
Config-Files.
Bam.
Add.
Desktop.
Ach, das ist ja Windows.
Ach du Scheiße.
Ja, das ist ja Windows.
Wie ging das jetzt nochmal, äh...
Äh...
Ja, manchmal geht mir Windows echt auf den...
Sack mit sowas.
Options.
Display.
Display-File-Extensions.
Irgendwo hier steht das doch.
Sieht's jemand?
Ach, hier, da.
Windows, ey.
Warum?
Warum macht's mir Windows immer so schwer?
Da ist es.
Activate.
Das war's?
Alter, das ist super easy.
Das ist super einfach.
Das ist, das ist wirklich.
Moment, Leute.
Das ist, das ist...
Eindeutig...
Easy as fuck.
Easy.
Das kann jeder.
Also das kann wirklich jeder.
Cute-Chat, genau.
Cute-AF-Chat.
Und das Ganze dann sogar noch mit nem QR-Code für Android.
Wollen wir das mal probier...
Also ich hab jetzt leider kein Android-Gerät da, was ich irgendwie streamen kann.
Aber wir können mal das generieren von dem...
Ähm...
Es generieren von dem QR-Code probieren.
Und ich kann das machen, das ist aber eh nicht von außen erreichbar.
Das ist super einfach!
Das, also das hat mich jetzt echt überzeugt, wenn das auch...
Ich hoffe, dass das auch ordentlich implementiert, dass das sicher...
Sicher ist.
Aber das ist echt geil!
Ich mein...
Die Config...
Dazu ...
Ganz ehrlich, dazu hätten wir nicht einmal diesen Guide hier gebraucht!
Das ist...
Wirklich super...
...simpel.
Das sind...
Das sind alle...
Ah...
Das sind hier 10 Zeilen Konfig, ne 8 Zeilen Konfig.
Die OpenVPN Konfig ist 10 mal so lang.
Hat nicht selbst Linus Weigert gelobt, kann schon sein.
Also das macht man einen wirklich durchdachten Eindruck.
Das ist easy as a fuck.
Android VM.
Gibt es mittlerweile ein gescheites Android?
Das probieren wir aus, wenn es das gibt.
Hat jemand Erfahrung damit?
Kennt jemand ein ordentliches Android für, ähm, für was ich, was ich in VM installieren kann?
Android Studio.
Ach Moment, das bringt mir ja gar nichts, ne.
Ich kann ja schlecht, ich kann ja schlecht ein QR-Code scannen von einer VM aus.
Aber wir generieren mal einen QR-Code.
Das muss ich jetzt nochmal ausprobieren.
Ich finde das richtig nice.
Das gefällt mir wirklich, das gefällt mir echt gut.
So, jetzt könnt ihr alle, jetzt könnt ihr alle mal ein VPN scannen und feststellen, dass ihr euch von außen nicht verbinden könnt.
Omega-Ludel.
Ist WireGuard schnell?
Gute Frage.
Wir können es mal von der VPN, wir können es mal von der VM in die VM ausprobieren, aber das ist nicht wirklich so aussagekräftig.
Ich will aber mal ausprobieren, was passiert.
Ne, wo ist das Bild?
Ach ne, das Bild ist noch temporär da, ne.
Ich will jetzt aber echt mal probieren, was passiert, wenn ich das scanne.
Äh, wo habe ich denn mein Tablet?
Tablet?
Hm, mein Tablet nicht hier.
Ich kann jetzt ja mal eine abscannen und gucken, ob es funktioniert.
Einfach einen QR-Scanner mal dran halten.
Ähm.
Okay, gibt es ein Android?
Für x86, g'schei, das, wie was von gehört.
Ist das euer 8.1 in VMware?
Okay, welches Image?
Wo ist das Image dafür?
Wo ist das, wo ist das Image?
Ja.
Moment, das ist Virtualbox, wir brauchen VMware.
Ich weiß halt nicht, wie vertrauenswürdig der Kram hier ist, ne.
Was?
Wissroms.com.
Sagt mir jetzt nichts.
Aha.
Okay, nice.
Das ist ein Android.
An open source OS based on Android.
Das ist irgendwo, ne.
Das kann man ja vor allem installieren.
Sind die auf GitHub, dann vertraue ich denen mehr.
Tatsächlich.
Sehr interessant.
Ist das alles ISO?
Gibt es den ganzen Download?
Download ist kaputt.
Das ist jetzt auch Premiere.
Habe ich schon nie gemacht.
Android in der 4M installiert.
Download, please.
Haha, jetzt wollen sie erstmal was verkaufen, ne.
Äh, BlizzOS x86.
Ach, fuck.
Only KVM und QEMU Emulation is currently supported.
Können wir nicht machen.
VMware Workstation, mögen sie anscheinend nicht.
Ist eh Mist noch, weiß ich nicht.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Müssen wir mal schauen, was es da gibt.
Aber ich mein, es reicht ja schon mal, was wir hier mit Windows ausprobiert haben.
Das ist wirklich super einfach.
Wir können jetzt nochmal gucken, was da so, was da so durchgeht durch das VPN.
Wohlgemerkt, das ist von VM zu VM.
Also Netzwerkprobleme, also Netzwerklimitierung haben wir hier wahrscheinlich relativ wenig.
Das ist von VM zu VM auf dem gleichen, ja, auf dem gleichen Host.
Ähm, wie kann man sich jetzt eigentlich anzeigen lassen?
Wer, wer alles connected ist?
Ah ja, hier, hier.
Das ist cool, das ist wirklich nice.
Ach, Moment.
Das bin ich selber, oder?
Ne.
Okay, pingen kann ich das Ganze nicht.
Was hat, was hat man Windows Client jetzt eigentlich für eine IP?
Ach, hier, Endpoint.
Ne, Moment mal.
Die IP müsste hier irgendwo sein.
Die IP müsste hier irgendwo drin sein.
Das, das hier bin ich.
Oder?
Das hier ist ja mein, mein.
Ne.
Moment.
Ich bin verwirrt.
Blockt Windows, sich Ping anfragen.
Das kann tatsächlich sein, dass es die Windows Firewall ist, die nicht will.
Äh, Turn off Windows Firewall.
Ähm.
Easy.
So sieht Security aus.
Ah.
Sehr gute Idee, Leute.
Twitch Chat.
Hilfreich.
Ja.
POG Chat.
Das wäre doch auch mal ein nicees Emote, oder?
Nicht POG Champ, POG Chat.
Hier.
POG.
Das gibt es bestimmt schon als Emote.
POG Chat.
Twitch Client for iOS.
Moment.
Es gibt einen Twitch Client für iOS?
Das brauche ich.
Der offizielle Twitch Client ist scheiße.
Geht nicht mehr.
POG Chat.
Ist down.
Das brauche ich.
Das geht aber bestimmt nur jailbreak oder so.
Nee, es gibt.
Es gibt.
Gibt es nicht mehr.
Twitch will das nicht.
Es gibt keine alternativen Twitch Apps für iOS.
Und die offizielle Twitch App ist Müll.
POG Chat.
Okay.
Also das ist unser Windows Client.
Dann machen wir jetzt mal IP Perf, ähm, IP Perf zwischen den beiden Systemen, würde
würde ich sagen das minus s genau machen
mal ein team max auf ipad minus es
würde nämlich mal schauen ob das ding
auch richtig lauscht am richtigen
interface
ok leuchtet an allen interfaces dann
brauchen wir nur noch ein ipad auf
windows und dann gucken wir mal wie
schnell also was vpn ist wohlgemerkt
das ist jetzt ein bisschen doofer test
ist gleiche vm auf dem gleichen haus
aber wir sollten zumindest schon mal
ungefähr abschätzen können was das ding
an cpu last verursacht weil ich meine
es läuft auf dem raspberry das werden
wir nämlich sehen was da durchgeht
wir machen vorher noch mal einen test
von diesem windows zu dem raspberry und
gucken was da durchgeht mal andere
sache wie kann ich einfach und schnell
auf einem ubuntu server die deutsche
zeit oder willst du willst du
zeitzone
zeitzone machst du mit dpkg reconfigure
tz weiß ich aus dem kopf nicht kann ich
aber gleich sagen
ach so mein internet funktioniert hier
auf windows nicht weil ich einfach pn
drin bin tz data so war's dpkg
reconfigure nicht tz tz data tz data
das sieht dann so aus
eurotimes sohn ist es eigentlich
verkehrt Berlin und dann stimmt die
uhrzeit auch ansonsten wenn du ein
tp server brauchst machst du auch da
gibt es ein system system die time
service system time also brauchst gar
keine tp mehr zu installieren das war
systemt mittlerweile dabei es ist
eigentlich fast alles timesync degen aus
ist mittlerweile was ist eigentlich gefühlt alles alles dabei weist den befehl jetzt gerade
nicht dafür da kannst du ntp an und ausschalten auf jeden fall drüber so ip wir probieren das
ist mal vom von dem windows ohne vpn und gucken was maximal drüber geht und dann probieren wir
es mit vpn und gucken was dann maximal drüber geht it's time to restore your device die
activate vpn ipad 3 für windows gift please da ist es zu quälen da hätte ich auch gleich
listening geht windows terminal wobei wir haben doch hier das gute terminal warum machen wir das
eigentlich in den mist haben wir haben extra die vm damals installiert um das neue windows
terminal zu testen dann dann auch machen wir das überhaupt zu kompliziert
da starten und so unser bunte unter windows das wobei das ist für ein performantest um wir machen
wir machen so ip-conf config ist jetzt wie sieht man die windows ip irgendwie so nah 65 moment das
ist ja das ja noch viel besser wie ich das gemacht habe so als wäre es so als wäre es
geplant das ding steht sogar schon in seinem eigenen netz ist ja noch ist ja noch viel besser
1 2 1 2 1 2 3?
Ne, äh, wie ging das?
Wie ist meine richtige IP hier vom Raspberry?
Noch 1 2 3.
Jetzt muss man einfach die IP eingeben.
Ich kann mir so Kram immer aus dem Kopf irgendwie so schlecht merken.
Aber pingen kann ich in meinem Raspberry, oder?
Äh, wie ging das?
Das war super easy eigentlich.
Cumulus Network.
Blablabla.
Ach, Minus C.
Minus C für Client.
Man könnte einfach so einstellen, dass Client Default ist.
Okay, also wir haben ungefähr...
Ja gut, sagen wir mal so...
Gigabit wäre theoretisch das Maximum.
125 MB die Sekunde.
Und wir haben ungefähr 85 MB die Sekunde.
Das ist okay.
Ich mein, das deckt sich auch ungefähr mit dem, was wir bei unserem Raspberry 4 Test hatten.
Ich mein...
Das Ziel ist immer noch ein Raspberry 4.
Da kann er sich allzu viel.
Das ist okay.
Ein bisschen weniger, weil ich mein, das ist von VM zu einem Raspberry und sowas.
Ich hab euch übrigens die ganze Zeit Scheiße erzählt.
Es ist nicht von VM zu VM.
Es ist von VM zu einem Raspberry 4.
Okay, so, und jetzt probieren wir das Ganze mal aus über VPN.
So, und da können wir wahrscheinlich einfach hier jetzt unseren Host nehmen.
Das ist 10 10 10 10 1.
Jawoll.
10 10 10 1.
Ja gut, es ist ein bisschen langsamer.
Es ist ein bisschen langsamer.
Wie macht man Unlimited Duration?
Geht das irgendwie?
Kann man da irgendwie Duration einstellen?
Dass der einfach permanent macht?
Ich mein, man konnte Count machen oder sowas, ne?
Das hatten wir doch erst letztens.
Hier, minus T 60.
Das hatten wir doch erst letztens, das gleiche Problem.
60, minus T 60.
So, also.
Wir kriegen ungefähr 36 Megabytes die Sekunde über das VPN mit einem Raspberry.
Der Raspberry, schauen wir uns mal die Auslastung an.
Der ist halt ganz gut beschäftigt.
Ein Kern auf Anschlag und die anderen auch ganz gut dabei.
Gut, IPF selber macht natürlich noch ein bisschen CPU Last.
Das andere sind irgendwelche Kernel-Module, die sehen wir jetzt hier nicht.
Aber es ist nicht schlecht für einen Raspberry.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich habe den Raspberry noch nie ausprobiert.
Hast du mal auf einem Raspberry OpenBSD...
Nein, habe ich noch nie probiert.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass Raspberry Pi OpenBSD Builds gibt.
Aber eigentlich ist es logisch, dass es welche gibt.
Also ich kann es nicht vergleichen.
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Was man an OpenVPN mit einem Raspberry durchkriegt.
Hat da vielleicht einer von euch Erfahrungen mit?
Ich weiß nicht, was man durchkriegt OpenVPN.
Können wir mal gucken, ob da jemand anderes Erfahrungen hat.
Schauen wir mal.
What speed can be attained OpenVPN on Pi 3?
Wir haben deutlich mehr als 30 Megabit pro Sekunde.
Wir haben 36 Megabyte die Sekunde.
Wir haben quasi 10 mal mehr ungefähr.
Als die Typen hier.
Aber das ist auch der...
Das ist aber auch der Dreier.
OpenVPN mit Zero.
Ja okay, das ist natürlich wirklich langsam.
3 bis 4 MB.
Guck mal, guck mal.
Hier schreibt einer sein Pi 3.
Kriegt gerade mal 3 bis 4 MB durch.
Durch OpenVPN.
Also wenn wir der Sache mal so glauben.
Und das ist ein Vierer.
Und sind mal großzügig und sagen.
Dass der Vierer OpenVPN.
Das Doppelte schafft.
Nämlich 8 oder sagen wir mal.
Aufrunden mit 10 MB.
Dann ist WireGuard doch ganz schön schnell.
Also da kann man nichts sagen.
VPN mit 35 MB die Sekunde.
Über einen Raspberry laufen.
Ist schon ordentlich.
Hast du mal von Arch.
Auf einem Raspberry probiert.
Das können wir eigentlich machen.
Ich installiere mal den gleichen Krams.
Jetzt mal auf meinem Host.
Erst mal hier kurz gucken.
Wie viel wir da haben.
Okay, also von meinem Linux.
Kriegen wir auf die.
Auf den Raspberry noch mehr.
Da sind wir.
Knapp am theoretischen Gigabit Maximum.
Es flutscht richtig gut.
Direkter Vergleich.
Mit OpenVPN wäre interessant.
Ich habe keinen Bock OpenVPN einzurichten.
OpenVPN einrichten ist ein Horror.
Nur IPsec ist noch komplizierter.
Das ist das Schöne.
Bei so Cisco Dingern.
Wenn man einfach nur 2-3 Befehle ausführt.
Und OpenVPN ist aktiviert.
Und an.
Aber nicht OpenVPN.
Ähm.
IPsec.
ZSH ist das.
WireGuard.
Das erleben wir mal.
Da gibt es doch bestimmt im Arch Wiki einen Eintrag zu.
WireGuard.
Jawoll.
Client.
Moment.
Ich brauche das alles gar nicht.
Ich brauche den WireGuard.
Client.
WireGuard Download.
Wie heisst denn das Ding?
Client.
Arch.
Ach so.
Das ist doch im Prinzip das gleiche.
Was ich hier auch drin hatte.
Sehe ich das richtig?
Dass Client und Server quasi in einem ist?
Könnte ich jetzt hier mit dem.
Hiermit auch einen.
Ach ich könnte hiermit auch einen Server aufmachen.
Ne oder?
Ne.
Oder doch?
Ich probiere WireGuard VPN aus.
Doch ich glaube ich könnte.
Ich glaube ich könnte damit wirklich einen WireGuard aufmachen.
Ok dann ist Client und ähm.
Dann ist das das gleiche.
Ok dann installieren wir den mal.
Brauchen wir eins und zwei.
Yes.
Ich glaube ich muss mal ein Update machen.
Das Minus Force lassen wir mal weg.
Ok ich muss ein Update machen.
Dann funktioniert es wahrscheinlich auch.
Omega Lul.
Relation.
Usage T.
Example Config.
Testing Tunnel.
Wie baut man jetzt hier eine Verbindung auf?
Das haben wir alle schon gemacht.
Hat das jemand schon mal gemacht?
Wie connectet man sich jetzt von einem Linux aus?
Zu einem WireGuard Server?
Wahrscheinlich auch damit.
Und dann WG WG irgendwie.
Konfig Datei oder so.
Ja.
Wahrscheinlich.
Dann werden wir gleich sehen wie das funktioniert.
Ok jetzt muss ich die Kram erst mal installieren.
Achso.
Ja das ist ja simpel.
Dann nehmen wir einfach unsere Client 1 Conf.
Und connecten das damit.
Ja das müsste doch eigentlich funktionieren.
Ok.
Dann müssen wir mal rebooten.
Weil Kernel Update und so Zeug.
Dann bin ich mal gespannt was wir da für eine Performance drüber kriegen.
Alles Profil.
Connecten wir uns auf den Raspberry.
Noch ein Stream.
Dann probieren wir mal WireGuard VPN.
Steht schon ne Weile auf der Agenda.
Was passiert hier eigentlich.
Ich versuche den VPN aufzubauen.
Zwischen Windows und dem Raspberry haben wir das schon gemacht.
Und zwischen meiner Linux Kiste und dem Raspberry probieren wir es jetzt.
Dann wollen wir mal gucken wie schnell das Ganze ist.
So dann kompilieren wir mal ne Runde.
Wenn der Max weiter so fleißig streamt,
kann er sich bald Gamer Grill Badewasser leisten.
Oh ja unbedingt.
mir nicht nur bald gamer grill badewasser leisten da kann ich mir bald ein komplettes gamer grill
leisten wenn ich weiter streben aber dazu muss ich erst mal partner werden ohne partner geht
da nichts warum weißt du sowas woher weißt du sowas immer twitter ja klar twitter wir müssen
uns übrigens nachher noch den max fps beziehungsweise wupplors discord angucken
müsst ihr noch um euren senf dazu geben also in form von was wir für channels brauchen und
emotes und zeug so dann schauen wir mal ob der kram jetzt funktioniert die client config die
können wir uns ja einfach kopieren da brauchen wir ja gar nichts großartiges ist es doch ja
das ist doch die client config diese ich sag euch dieser clipboard meiner scheiße ist
übrigens nicht so gut wie der clipboard meiner scheiße ist übrigens nicht so gut wie der clipboard meiner scheiße
praktisch hier ist das falsche was ich kopiert habe aber im prinzip ist der sehr praktisch
so connecten wir uns exakt mit der gleichen ip und allem wie vorher wie von windows aus von
linux aus jetzt muss ich nur mal gucken wie das ganze funktioniert sagt man jetzt einfach
wire guard wire guard wie ging das jetzt wire guard up
wg quick wg quick weil auch immer quick klein 1 ab klein 1 you must be rude ja okay ach so okay
ist gut machen wir cp home max home test klein 1 conf nach etc wire guard etc wire guard
und dann braucht das ding mit sicherheit noch die richtigen credentials wie wg quick cp hektar
up klein 1 sein ist jetzt funktioniert oder nicht wie soll kommt not found wer
habe ich anscheinend besetzern nicht gebraucht sein wie soll kommt 14
um harmonischen funktionen
ich eigentlich keine ResolveConf. So ne ResolveConf. Aber kein Befehl. Okay, was auch immer. Dann,
äh, tja, was installieren wir da jetzt? Keine Ahnung. So. Und jetzt gucken wir mal,
ob's funktioniert. Bäm. Nee. I. Doch. Hat funktioniert. Bäm. Funktioniert. Sehr schön,
nice. So, und jetzt machen wir mal den gleichen Performancetest nochmal. Also,
wir hatten den hier. Das ist ohne VPN. Ohne VPN kriegen wir quasi über die gleiche,
also die gleiche Strecke mehr oder weniger. Ist das ja zum gleichen Zielsystem. Kriegen
wir knapp einen Gigabit hin. Und über VPN kriegen wir ungefähr das gleiche wie unter Windows. Bisschen
schneller wie unter Windows. So ein paar MB, so zwei, drei MB schneller als unter Windows.
Benutzt du einen Windowmanager? Das ist I3WM. I3WM ist, hat ein komplett anderes Konzept wie
die meisten anderen Windows-Windows. Also, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist,
es hat, es gibt kein Windows-Windows in dem Sinne. Ich mein, du kannst du Windows machen,
ja aber standardmäßig ist es so, dass alles im Fullscreen ist und wenn du ein zweites Programm
startest, sich das quasi teilt. Du kannst natürlich schon einstellen, wie ich das machen soll,
und, und, wie du das angeordnet haben willst. Und du kannst auch das rausmachen zu ne Window,
aber du verbringst eigentlich kaum noch Zeit mit Windowmanagement. Guck mal, es hat sich jetzt
eingependelt. Es ist jetzt ein bisschen schneller geworden. Also, wie sagen wir mal, es ist so, es
4,5 MB schneller.
Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen Awesome,
dass er nicht so viel Config braucht?
Ansonsten kannst du da ziemlich ähnliche Sachen machen.
Dann ist es einfacher zu konfigurieren.
Aber das ist nice.
Guckt mal.
Im Durchschnitt 40 MB
über einen VPN.
Was ist sein Ziel mit dem VPN?
Ich will gucken, wie schnell es mit einem Raspberry 4 ist.
Ich meine, der ist ziemlich am Anschlag.
Mehr geht da nicht.
Aber es ist nice.
Ich meine, OpenVPN ist schon langsam dagegen.
Mit OpenVPN hätten wir vielleicht 10 MB die Sekunde.
Und mit WireGuard haben wir 40 MB die Sekunde.
Und wir haben das schon großzügig aufgerundet,
was wir an Benchmarks,
oder naja, was heißt an Benchmarks,
was wir an Ergebnissen zu OpenVPN gefunden haben,
haben wir schon großzügig aufgerundet,
um mehr als das Doppelte.
Ist WireGuard das schnellste VPN, den du kennst?
Ich muss dir ehrlich sagen,
ich habe noch nie VPN-Bandbreiten-Benchmarks oder so gemacht.
Also auf dem passenden Gerät
ist IPsec mit Sicherheit auch saumäßig schnell.
Aber WireGuard ist wirklich sehr zackig.
Ich meine, das ist ein Raspberry.
Das ist jetzt nicht,
dass wir da was mit super Power hinten dran hätten.
Also da bin ich echt positiv jetzt von überrascht,
dass das Ding 40 MB die Sekunde kriegt.
Und ich meine, man sieht es,
der Raspberry ist dicht.
Man sieht hier 2,25 MB.
25, 25% CPU-Auslastung.
Aber WireGuard ist halt ein Kernel-Modul.
Das sieht man nicht so easy in dem Fall.
Und ich denke mal,
dass der erste Core quasi komplett mit WireGuard zu ist
und die anderen halt die Multithreading-Anteile von WireGuard.
Aber das ist nice.
Also es ist wirklich gut.
Und wenn man jetzt mal von aus geht,
man verwendet das Ganze mit,
mit sagen wir mal 3, 4 Leuten oder so parallel.
Gehen wir mal von aus.
Hier was sehe ich?
Vater, Mutter, zwei Kinder.
Und jeder ist irgendwie per VPN mit seinem Smartphone.
Hat er da eine Verbindung aufgebaut.
Da könnten sogar,
wenn es die, wohlgemerkt,
wenn es die Internetverbindung daheim hergibt,
könnten alle vier sich Full-HD-Sachen streamen.
Locker.
Ist doch nice.
Also da kannst du wirklich nichts sagen.
Ich meine gut, man braucht erstmal eine Internetanbindung,
die 350 MBit schafft.
Ich habe euch ja vorhin erzählt,
ich habe die Telekom gekündigt.
Und es gibt jetzt Unity Media mit 40 ab und 400 down bei mir.
Da bin ich leider weit davon entfernt,
dass ich WireGuard theoretisch ordentlich ausnutzen könnte.
Aber es ist trotzdem cool.
Der Winky sagt, er benutzt PIA als VPN.
Kenn ich nicht.
Was ist denn PIA VPN?
Achso.
Ich muss mal WireGuard ausmachen.
Äh.
Moment.
WG quick down.
Down.
Klein 1.
So, jetzt geht mein Internet auch wieder klein.
Ist das PIA VPN?
Habe ich noch nie gehört, ehrlich gesagt.
Das ist aber,
das ist nichts, was du selbst hostest, oder?
Sponsor von Linux Tech Tips.
Gucke ich ganz selten.
Gucke ich auch, ehrlich gesagt,
eher wegen dem Entertainment Faktor und nicht,
weil man da so die Weisheiten erfährt.
Ja, haben nicht Router schon oft eine VPN Sache an Bord?
Doch, aber je nach Router sind die auch nicht sonderlich geschwind.
Oder aber dein Router kann nicht das VPN, was du verwenden willst.
Ich habe mir letzten sagen lassen, dass OpenVPN unter MikroTik,
hat jemand im Stream erzählt, wohl ziemlicher Crap sein muss,
sowohl vom Speed her als auch von der Implementierung her.
Kann ich weder B noch Widerlegen.
Ich habe es noch nicht ausprobiert.
Ich könnte es ausprobieren.
IPsec kommt für mich nicht in Frage,
weil IPsec, die Implementierung auf iOS,
ist ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Du kannst zum Beispiel keine unterschiedlichen Routen haben.
IPsec unter iOS kann nur alles durch den Tunnel leiten.
Und das will ich ja gerade mit einem Smartphone nicht.
Wenn ich mit einem Smartphone ein VPN aufmache,
dann will ich nur eine spezielle Route oder zwei spezielle Routen über das VPN leiten.
Nämlich die, die in mein Heimnetz gehen.
Die will ich komplett in Internet-Traffic durch mein VPN schleusen.
Das ist so kompletter Blödsinn.
Ich will einfach nur die Route quasi für meine Nextcloud oder so will ich pushen.
Und das geht über IPsec mit, über iOS nicht.
Übrigens, weil wir gerade gesagt haben, Entertainment,
ein richtig, richtig nicer Channel für Leute,
die sich ein bisschen,
die sich auch für Elektronik-Kram interessieren,
den ich übelst lustig finde,
ist der, der ist aber ziemlich groß.
Der hat auch schon zwei Millionen Abos oder so.
Nee, ist er nicht.
Doch hier, der.
Hi, der da.
How to make an electric...
Elektro-Boom.
2,6 Millionen Abos.
Und der macht das wirklich gut.
Der verbindet ziemlich gut quasi, dass man was lernt mit lustigen Sachen.
Und.
Er kriegt so circa zehn Elektro-Schläge pro Video gefühlt, ja.
Er kriegt schon immer Panik.
Ich meine, allein schon das Thumbnail sollte alle sagen, ja.
Den kann man aber wirklich...
Den kann man sich aber wirklich angucken.
Der ist wirklich gut.
Das ist jemand, wo ich sage, ey, voll verdient 2,6 Millionen Abos.
Informationsreiche Videos und gleichermaßen lustige Videos.
Der TmaxElectronics guckt den auch.
Ah ja.
Na gut.
Der hat auch schon Electronics im Namen.
Ups.
Das PPGA-Board ist kaputt.
Warum ist das PPGA-Board kaputt?
Ah, wegen VPN, ne?
Und wegen Reboot.
PPGA-Board ist kaputt.
Sind alle Fragen, hat es nicht aufgenommen.
Mach Software, RIP.
Hey, meine Software, so gut sie oder schlecht sie sein mag, mit Reboot überlebt sie noch nicht.
Das, wenn das mal einer erfindet, quasi Reboot-Proof-Software, dann kann er was verdienen, ja.
Wohlgemerkt auf dem gleichen Rechner weiterlaufen.
Ja, irgendwelche Sachen mal createn oder so, kann jeder.
Muss übrigens mal sagen, dass ich es übelst nice finde, dass ich gerade um die 100 Zuschauer habe,
bei quasi super random Laber-Stream, ohne Ankündigung, ohne alles.
Freitagnachmittag, also Freitagmittag, wo Leute noch arbeiten bis Freitagnachmittag.
Da ist das PPGA-Board wieder.
Laberstells ist beliebt.
Müsste IPsec nicht bei IPv6 standardmäßig für alle LTS-Verbindungen genutzt werden und hat nicht direkt was mit VPN zu tun?
Hä?
Äh...
Nee?
Oder?
Also es sei denn, die machen ganz merkwürdige Dinger bei IPv6, was mich nicht wundern würde.
Aber ich wüsste jetzt nicht, was IPsec mit TLS an sich groß...
Also mit SSL oder HTTPS so großartig zu tun hat.
So, habe ich irgendwas im Chat überlesen.
Gibt schnelle OpenVPN Installer Bash-Skripts weiter weiter fertig.
Die könnten das noch machen, aber...
Ich glaube, das müssen wir gar nicht ausprobieren, das wird deutlich schneller sein.
Ich schreibe mir aber mal in meine Stream-To-Do's auf,
dass wir das mal ausprobieren mit Android auf Vmware laufen zu lassen.
Was es da gibt.
Ankommen neue Black Desert... Black Desert...
Ne, Black Desert spielt...
Der Fabian spielt jetzt meinen Account.
Weil er irgendwie so einen No-Pay-To-Win ohne Cash-Shop Account spielen will.
Das heißt, wenn ich mich jetzt wahrscheinlich mal wieder einlogge auf meinen Account,
habe ich da wahrscheinlich jetzt irgendwie 5 Level 62er mit Ultra-Gear oder so drauf.
Der Fabian geht ja immer ab.
Hallo Orangensaft 9, habe ich gar nicht gelesen, Freund.
So, ist da Sbarro oder der Patrick am Start?
Oder beide?
Wollen wir uns das jetzt mit dem Discord...
Ah, alle beide, sehr gut.
Wir gucken uns das jetzt mit dem Discord an.
Habt ihr da gerade Zeit für?
Achso, wie ist denn mein Discord?
Ich muss euch mal kurz ausmachen.
Ähm...
Mal gucken, nicht, dass mein Discord komische Dinge anzeigt.
Ich hab einfach mal die Szene geswitcht.
Äh...
Mein Discord... Ich muss mein Discord noch in Streaming-Modus stellen.
Genau, die News der E-Grillen sollen nicht direkt zu sehen sein.
Aber Patrick scheint sich da auszukennen.
Achso, ist alles schon aktiviert?
Äh...
Discord hat mich gerade eingeloggt, wieder ausgeloggt und wieder eingeloggt.
Okay, keine Ahnung, was auch immer.
Äh, passt wohl schon.
Okay, also.
Der MaxFPS Discord-Server.
Der Sbarro und der Patrick, also TheGame402 im Chat.
Die haben sich das Ganze schon angeguckt und mal aufgesetzt.
Und was da jetzt standardmäßig drin ist, sind halt so ein paar Sachen, die...
Wo sie gedacht haben, die passen gut zum Streamen.
Das heißt, wir müssen uns das Ganze jetzt mal anschauen.
Und gucken, ob das so passt, was wir machen können.
Ah ja, und wir müssen natürlich das Darkstream einschalten.
Wo schaltet man im Discord nochmal das Darkstream ein?
Achso.
Stimmt, das ist...
Nee, nur mein Chat ist nicht...
Nur mein Chat ist nicht...
Äh.
Der Chat ist weiß.
Ja gut, da kann man nichts gegen machen.
Einfach aufpassen wegen Sbarro seinen Monkatoß-Bildern.
Ähm, in welchem Channel hat er Sbarro Monkatoß-Bilder gepostet?
Nur dass ich das weiß, dass ich da nicht reingehe.
Ah.
Ja, so ist doch viel schöner, oder?
Im Weep-Spam-Channel.
Da...
Außer in den Weep-Chann-
Okay.
Alter.
Nicht, dass es jetzt hier MonkaTos gibt, weil das hier baro Dinger spammt.
Also, was haltet ihr für sinnvolle Channels?
Also ich bin der Ansicht, ich habe mir das ja schon mal angeguckt,
ich bin der Ansicht, wir sollten mit ein bisschen weniger Channels starten,
weil umso mehr Channels man hat, umso mehr verteilen sich die Leute
und umso inaktiver und leerer wirkt das.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass das hier ein Exquisite-Discord ist,
wo wir dann auf einmal 150.000 Leute oder so drin haben.
Also ich denke zum Beispiel, dass wir Off-Topic, Foodporn und Musik in einem machen könnte.
Warum Discord?
Weil TS nur Gelaber ist, TS kaum einer verwendet und Discord alle möglichen anderen Features hat.
Also ich denke, dass man zum Beispiel, genau, dass man das alles in einem machen könnte,
dass man Musik und Foodporn und Off-Topic alles in eins machen könnte.
Genau, so.
Ein Memes-Dings.
Das ist okay.
So Ankündigungen, da sieht man glaube ich immer, wenn mein Stream online geht,
das ist schon mal sehr nice.
Eingangshalle braucht man, braucht man die?
Ja, gut, irgendeinen Default-Channel braucht man.
Wollen wir die vielleicht nicht Eingangshalle nennen, sondern irgendwie anders?
Irgendwie, habt ihr eine gute Idee, wie man das Ding nicht Eingangshalle, sondern General, ja.
Genau, einfach global irgendwas.
Ja, General finde ich ganz gut.
Nenn es einfach General.
Keksthose.
Okay, Themenvorschläge, das ist ein Channel, den finde ich wichtig,
wenn man irgendwie, wenn irgendwie einem was in den Sinn kommt, wo ich mich mal drüber auslassen könnte,
im Stream oder in einem Video, ja, also ab und zu sollte es ja nochmal vorkommen,
dann kann man es da reinklatschen.
Stream Talk.
Wozu ist das gedacht?
Magst Videos in 2K90, ne?
Text-Channel.
Wie Twitch-Chat nur oft, ah ne, da haben wir Twitch-Chat für.
Also ich denke, wir brauchen keinen generellen Chat und, und einen Stream-Talk.
Wir müssen uns auch mal über, aber wir lassen es jetzt erstmal so.
Müssen wir mal gucken, ob es hier wirklich so, weil, weil die Frage ist ja, wenn man einen Channel Off-Topic nennt,
und ein General, da weiß keiner so genau,
was kommt jetzt in Off-Topic und was kommt, was kommt in General rein.
Vielleicht sollten wir sogar auch mal,
oder Leute, was, was sagt ihr? Brauchen wir einen Off-Topic?
Weil ich meine im Prinzip, wenn da nicht zu, wenn, das machen wir dann, wenn zu viel los sein sollte
und zu viel gespammt wird oder so, dann können wir unterschiedliche Channels machen,
aber standardmäßig können wir einfach einen General-Channel machen
und vielleicht später noch einen Off-Topic.
Themenvorschläge, den finde ich wichtig, das ist gut.
Streamsor, ah, lol.
Ähm, das ist ein Voice-Channel.
Der Voice-Channel für Streams ist gar nicht schlecht,
falls ich mal irgendwann wieder was spielen sollte mit dem E-Ax oder so zusammen,
ähm, dann kann man das verwenden, das ist schon mal nicht verkehrt.
Mal kurz nachputzen.
So, ähm, Development-Text-Channels, ja.
Ähm, also Proggers sollten wir auf jeden Fall behalten.
Ja, es ist 0, ich würde sagen, wir gucken uns das mal an.
Wie viel da wirklich, was da wirklich kommt, ob es sinnvoll ist, dass man da noch einen Off-Topic macht.
Äh, also den Proggers-Channel sollten wir behalten.
Ich denke, wir brauchen, wir können, also ich glaube den,
also ich würde sagen, den News-Channel in der Form braucht man,
ich weiß nicht, braucht man einen News-Channel?
Weil, könnt ihr Channel-Beschreibung in den Settings machen, dass die Leute das checken?
Das ist eine gute Idee, ja.
Das lassen wir erstmal so, würde ich sagen.
Ja.
Channel-Beschreibungen sind nicht verkehrt.
Technik-Chat, die Neuheiten-China-Crap.
Ähm, ich glaube, ich glaube letztendlich wird es hier auch, wird es hier auch ein Channel tun.
Ja, es wäre geil, wenn man den Off-Topic-Channel per Bot-Command hervorrufen würde.
Na, das, wir gucken erstmal, wie viel da wirklich ist.
Ja, wir gucken erstmal, wie viel da wirklich ist.
Ja, und vielleicht nennen wir das Ding dann noch irgendwie, anstatt China, nennen wir einfach,
keine Ahnung, vielleicht, vielleicht machen wir einfach, ähm, müssen wir uns einen guten Namen noch für überlegen.
So, und, ähm, das müsste eigentlich unter Developer-Channels, kann ich das selbst machen?
Ich mach mal lieber nix selbst, ja.
Mach ich noch kaputt.
Ähm, und, ich glaube, wir, wir machen, das geht nicht, C-Route.
Hehehe.
Also, vielleicht sollten wir die, die Verschmutzung,
die verschiedenen Sprach-Channels, äh, also die verschiedenen Channels, der, mit den verschiedenen, mit den verschiedenen Sprachen sollten wir lassen.
Aber auf der anderen Seite, ähm, glaube ich, so viel wird es da, wird es da nicht geben.
Das muss man nochmal überlegen.
Das gucken wir uns nochmal an, wie das funktioniert.
Oder was wir machen.
Ähm, Gaming, also generell, könnte, könnte man nicht einfach sagen, wir machen, wir machen, also diese, wir machen die, wir machen die Gruppen weg.
Wir machen einfach nen, nen Proggas-Channel, wir machen nen, nen, nennen wir es mal Proggas-Hilfe-Channel, wir machen nen Technik-Channel und wir machen nen Gaming-Channel.
Weißt du, wie ich mein?
Einfach, einfach, dass man ein bisschen weniger, dass auch erstens klar ist, für jeden, wo was rein soll und dass es weniger, weniger Zerstreuung dazwischen gibt.
Cute Chat.
Elektronik-Channel hatten wir schon.
Äh, den haben wir aber weggemacht.
Den können wir unter Technik einfach, hier, guck mal, Highspeed editiert wird das Ganze.
Sehr schön.
Naja, das, das gefällt mir jetzt schon viel besser.
Oh, wow.
Ach ja, jetzt ist das.
So.
Ah, das ist, hm.
Cute Chat.
Moment, darf ich Cute Chat aufmachen oder kommen dann die 18 Plus Bilder vom Sibaro?
Kannst aufmachen, okay.
Weep Spam darf ich nicht aufmachen, oder?
Ähm, ähm, ähm.
Ach Gott, wartet mal.
Okay, ich würd sagen, wir lassen die, genau, wir machen die Programmier-Hilfe-Channels erstes Mal weg für die einzelnen Sprachen, hast du ja schon gemacht.
So, wir haben General Memes Ankündigung.
Das, das lassen wir mal drinne.
Kann man, da können wir auch so Dinger machen, wie, äh, es gibt mal ein neues YouTube-Video oder sowas, falls es sowas gibt.
Äh, Themenvorschläge, Stream-Software, Voice-Chat, äh, Proggers, Hilfe, ja, Cute Chat.
Lama stellt eins und zwei.
Und Admin-Gedöns.
Das reicht doch erst mal.
Okay, also wir haben jetzt relativ zusammengestaucht das Ganze.
Gibt's noch irgendwas, wo ihr sagt, das sollten wir...
Nee, lass mal, ich frag den Fabian.
Außerdem weiß ich nicht, inwieweit es die Leute interessiert.
Die weißten wahrscheinlich gar kein Video.
Hier, gucken.
Ähm, man könnte das höchstens als Command irgendwie machen.
Ähm, genau.
Habt ihr noch irgendwelche Vorschläge, was wir unbedingt machen sollen, müssen?
Ähm, ähm.
Weil ansonsten würde ich sagen...
Aber da kommt drauf an, was der Patrik und der Sebaro sagen.
Können wir schon mal einen Invite-Link erstellen?
Also wenn alles passt und wenn Berechtigungen passen.
Wir machen keinen Hentai-Channel.
Das ist Monkatos.
Aber klicke ich dann im Stream aus Versehen auf den falschen Channel und gleich Instant-Bun.
Dann ist das schon der richtige Link.
Nice.
Sehr schön.
Ach so, ja übrigens, ich hätte noch einen Emote-Vorschlag.
Anstatt dem da...
Brauchen wir den...
Brauchen wir den Monka...
Den Monka-Kiga oder so, den ich im Chat habe.
Den mit den großen Augen ohne rangezoomt.
Guck mal, es gibt sogar meinen Keks als Emote.
Aber ohne...
Oh, da brauchen wir noch einen transparenten Keks.
Da brauchen wir noch einen transparenten Keks.
Ja, Emotes müssen wir noch ein paar hinzufügen.
Vor zwei Wochen, okay.
Ja, ich hab eine transparente.
Ich hab eine transparente Variante von meinem Keks.
Okay, nice.
Ähm...
Kann man den Channel noch MaxFPS-Wupplos oder so nennen?
Weil es gibt bestimmt die ein oder anderen, die tatsächlich nur das von Twitch kennen.
Oder geht's einfach unbedingt nicht?
Ah, so, perfekt.
Willst du deinen Twitch-Handle behalten?
Hä?
Du meinst den Name auf Twitch oder was?
Warum nicht?
Also...
Ach so, der Strich?
Nee, hä?
Was meinst du?
Äh, Kriegsions.
So, ich mach den Rest-Match mal wieder aus.
Der Test hat ja wunderbar funktioniert.
Hat schon viele, äh.
Auf einen Schlag.
Okays.
Äh, die gesperrten Channels siehst du wahrscheinlich jetzt nur, weil ich hier im Stream eingeloggt bin, denke ich mal.
Ja, ja, Wupplos will ich behalten.
Du meinst, warum ich mich nicht auf MaxFPS auf Twitch nenne?
Ähm...
Jetzt liegt...
Ja, eigentlich ursprünglich war es mal einen privaten Account, wo ich überhaupt nie vorhatte, damit was zu streamen.
Ähm...
Auf der anderen Seite finde ich...
Insofern ganz gut, weil es gibt auf YouTube auch noch genug Deppen und die bringen das hier dann gar nicht mit in Verbindung.
Also ich...
Ich lass das erstmal so.
Den...
Ich könnte mich sogar, glaube ich, jederzeit umbenennen, weil ich habe, glaube ich, irgendwo noch...
Also ich glaube, ich habe mir MaxFPS damals sogar auf Twitch gesichert.
Also das heißt, ich verfüge auch über den Account dann.
Ja, mal gucken.
Aber ich werde das...
Und man kann sich jetzt ja umbenennen.
Aber ich werde...
Tf...
Äh, hallo?
Tf?
Äh, ab und zu.
OKS?
Was?
Ah ja, OK.
Mikrofon.
Spackt.
So, sehr nice.
Da könnt ihr euch austoben im Discord.
Ähm...
Mal schauen, was wir damit in Zukunft noch machen.
YouChat.
Oh, das...
Da sind sie hier unter sich jetzt.
Das darf ich...
Ich weiß jetzt schon, das darf ich im Stream nicht aufmachen, ey.
Nee, nee, Miraki.
Mirikari.
Das ist...
Es ist ein Unterschied, ob du den gleichen Namen hast.
Sehr schön.
Ja, mal gucken, was wir damit machen.
Ähm...
Ich hatte mir ja schon vor Ewigkeiten mal einen Discord angelegt, hier unten.
Da bin ich aber nur mit dem Fabian zu zweit drin.
Und mach nix, ja.
Wir machen noch einen Discord.
Einen Discord, ähm...
Discord-Command machen wir noch.
M-Core and Friends.
Den gibt's auch noch.
XQC.
Warum bin ich eigentlich bei XQC gejoined?
Ich glaub, weil er mal irgendwann Overwatch-Games, äh, OVL-Games quasi kommentiert hat bei sich im Channel.
Okay, nice.
Ähm, da haben wir die Discord-Sache jetzt auch...
Ach, das ist in Random-Text, ne?
Da haben wir die Discord-Sache jetzt auch, ähm, gestartet.
Da klicke ich jetzt nicht drauf.
Wer weiß, was da drin ist.
Ja, also wenn es irgendwie irgendwelche Themen gibt, wenn irgendjemand Hilfe bei irgendwelchen Programmiergeschichten braucht,
bei irgendwelchen Elektronikgeschichten,
wenn er irgendwie Heimautoma...
Ach, ja!
Sollen wir vielleicht noch einen Heimautomatisierungs-Channel machen?
Oder passt der...
Oder passt der hier bei Technik ganz gut hin?
Dann lass uns doch die...
Dann lass uns doch die Development-Channels...
Lass die mal einfach Technik oder so nennen.
Und dann machen wir einen Progress-Channel
und einen Heimautomatisierungs-Channel
und, ähm...
Ja, Rest können wir so lassen.
So, und Hilfe können dann die Leute rein-spammen, die, äh, Pack-a-Loss haben
oder wo die Port-Weiterleitung auf die Playstation nicht funktioniert oder so Zeug,
was wir alle schon im Stream in letzter Zeit hatten.
Weil das funktioniert einfach deutlich besser,
als wenn ich da im Stream zwei Minuten mal meinen Senf dazugebe,
weil man kann vieles einfach nicht richtig so diagnostizieren.
Und wenn da aber irgendwie einer Zeit und Bock hat, den Leuten zu helfen,
wäre das natürlich nice.
Sehr schön.
Das gewinnt.
Hier unten werde ich im Stream nicht draufklicken.
Da habe ich zu viel Angst, dass da irgendeiner Zeug postet.
Progress.
Sehr schön.
Nice.
Ja, Leute, ähm...
2 Stunden 46 schon wieder.
Und ich sage, die Zeit geht immer viel schneller rum, als man denkt.
Ja, sogar der Musik-Stream ist fast vorbei.
Für das, dass wir nichts vorhatten, haben wir wieder...
Ziemlich viel gemacht.
Inklusive WireGuard VPN.
Und ich bin echt überrascht von der WireGuard-Geschichte, muss ich ehrlich zugeben.
Vor allem die Config ist super einfach gewesen.
Huge.
Massive.
Simple.
Ja, gibt's doch irgendwas.
Ansonsten gehe ich jetzt, glaube ich, mal eine Runde Abendessen.
Und ich glaube, es ist auch für meinen Hals ganz gut, wenn ich nicht gar so lange labere,
dass ich nächste Woche wieder fit bin.
Und...
Vielleicht...
Vielleicht schaffe ich's ja.
Jetzt hier direkt im Anschluss.
Ich hole mir einfach was zu futtern.
Dann setze ich mich wieder an den Rechner.
Und mache mal meine Partnerbewerbung für Twitch.
Was hältst du von der Idee, eine 1660 zum Encoden in deinen PC einzubauen?
Wenn die auch den guten Encoder hat.
Finde ich die Idee gar nicht so schlecht.
Ja, eben, ich stream ja die ganze Zeit jetzt schon über NVENC.
Man merkt's jetzt nicht so richtig.
Ich meine, statisches Desktop-Zeug.
Das kostet eine 1660.
217, 200.
Das könnte man sich tatsächlich mal überlegen.
Und Idle brauchen die Dinger jetzt auch nicht wahnsinnig viel Strom.
Ich glaube, die können mittlerweile sogar H265, oder?
Ich meine, sogar der Raspberry kann H265.
Das ist, finde ich, sogar keine schlechte Idee.
Das probiere ich vielleicht aus.
Habe ich eigentlich mit Company 3 auf?
Benutzt deinen Raspberry zum Streamen.
Easy.
So machen wir's.
Partnerschaft bewerben. Wir müssen nur einige Dinge prüfen, bevor du dich für eine Partnerschaft bewerben kannst. Du musst eine verifizierte E-Mail-Adresse besitzen. Hast du bereits ein festes Publikum auf YouTube oder Twitter? Ja, Twitter. YouTube muss ich noch connecten. Ich mache das hier gleich im Anschluss vom Stream.
Ich wurde jetzt die letzten Tage ja so gedrängt, endlich mal mein Partnerschritt da zusammen zu kriegen. Da wird echt mal Zeit.
Pusht du eigentlich noch die aktuelle Version vom Memeboard? Ne, die aktuelle Version ist Müll. Also die aktuelle Version funktioniert bei mir lokal und ist total unsauber und crap.
Was ich mal wirklich pushen könnte, ist das Pepega-Board. Also die Chat-Geschichte. Da müssen wir allerdings noch eine Sache einbauen.
Das machen wir vielleicht im nächsten Stream. Wir müssen das ein bisschen customisable machen, dass man nämlich die Channel und sowas customisieren kann.
Weil ich glaube, es will keiner eine Chat mit Log-Software haben, die hardcoded auf Wubblos geht.
Willst du den Twitch-Name so lassen oder auf Max-FPS ändern lassen?
Also prinzipiell würde ich sagen, ich lasse es so. Allerdings würde ich mir dann vielleicht an der Stelle sogar auch mal anhören, was da Twitch dazu sagt.
Und was sie vorschlagen, wenn sie denn was vorschlagen.
Ich gehe nämlich mal davon aus, dass die sagen werden, es wäre auf jeden Fall besser, sich umzubenennen, dass es mehr Leute finden.
Auf der anderen Seite ist das halt so eine Sache. Gerade deshalb habe ich mich nicht so genannt.
Ich habe ja den anderen Channel.
Boah, ich muss mal gucken, habe ich den?
Mal gucken, wen man findet.
Ich bilde mir aber ein, ich habe den Channel irgendwo.
Naja, aber das muss ich mir mal überlegen dann.
Okay, dann gehe ich jetzt was essen.
Es war wieder nice, dass ihr alle am Start wart.
Auch wenn das heute ein bisschen planlos war.
Weil wir eigentlich gar nicht genau wussten, was wir machen sollen.
Haben wir trotzdem noch ganz sinnvoll gefüllt, die Zeit.
Gucken, ob jemand on ist, den man hosten kann.
Dem folge ich denn, den ich hosten möchte.
Ey, ich habe keine Leute mit 12k, ey, das ist komplett...
...komplett beknackt.
Virus könnten wir wieder hosten.
Würde allerdings gerne lieber mal einen...
...kleinen hosten.
Wir gucken jetzt noch mal schnell, wer...
...auf Twitch...
...wer Science Techno...wer, wer Programming streamt.
Gucken wir jetzt mal.
Ich verwecke das jetzt. Ich finde diese Kategorie hört sich immer an wie Scientology.
Air...Earthquake 3D Live.
Was, was, was? Gibt es auf Twitch alles?
Ja.
Jaja, wir brauchen auch ein Ausrufezeichen Discord-Command.
Der Sibaro weiß aber, wie man das über den Chat anlegt.
Der ist da...ich hab...ich weiß nicht, wie das...ich kann das anlegen über das Admin-Interface.
Was ist das?
Man sieht, wo es Erdaschütterungen gibt oder so.
ASP.NET Core 2.2 Workshop.
Ey, du hast keine Rechte zum Command-Anlegen?
Klar, du musst Rechte zum Command-Anlegen haben.
Weil alle Commands...
...die...fast alle Commands, die mittlerweile angelegt sind, habe ich nicht selbst angelegt.
So, kann man das filtern nach...nach German...
...Language...
Aua, 3D-Printer!
Moment, was ist das für ein Stream?
Das ist ja einfach die...die...Octoprint-Kamera am 3D-Printer dran.
Warum?
Warum...warum streamt man seinen 3D-Drucker?
So kann man auch Views bekommen, ja wahnsinnig viele.
Ist das ein Prusa?
MK...Dings...3?
Sieht von den Farben ein bisschen so aus.
Remote...genau, Remote-Überwachung, nur in Billig.
Wirtschaft für Schüler und Studierende.
What?
Ihh, BWL-Kram, geh weg!
Java?
Oh, da könnt ihr noch...was wird das wohl?
Ich würde sagen, ein 3D-Drucker.
Achso, das, was er ausdruckt.
Das ist irgendeine...irgendeine Figur.
Okay, was haben wir denn hier zu bieten?
PHP?
Boah, das ist ja mal was, ja.
Ewig nicht mehr gesehen.
Ja, gäbe es jetzt irgendwelche deutschen Programming-Grills, die...
...programmen würden, dann würde ich natürlich sofort den Host raushauen, aber...
...so wie das halt ist in der IT-Landschaft, zum größten Teil nur Typen am Start.
Oh, ne.
Jetzt habe ich...jetzt habe ich ja was gesagt.
Jetzt sind wir ja gleich, äh...
...sind wir ja gleich die Feministen am Start, ähm...
Ich darf es dir heute nichts mehr sagen in der Richtung.
Ganz, ganz gefährlich.
Ähm, Java Game Engine.
Ich glaube, wir hosten den Java Game Engine-Typ.
Oh, das sieht kompliziert aus.
Und es ist Java.
Oder, we...wem wollen wir hosten?
Den, äh, den PHP?
Den, den Typ mit PHP?
Oder...
Moment, ist das nicht...ist das nicht der Typ von Unge hier?
Ist das nicht der Typ von Unge?
Sieht so aus, oder?
Das war der doch.
Wer hat die Methodennamen auf Deutsch?
Er?
Wer...wer hat seine Methoden auf Deutsch?
Das ist doch...das ist doch mal was.
Ich sehe hier keine Methoden auf Deutsch.
Te...
Texture...Texture-Schatten.
Ja, warum nicht?
Noch mal was.
Was, gab es Fehler? Ich kann es...
Ich...ich sehe es überhaupt nicht.
Wo ist es, Leute? Guidet mich!
Wo ist mal meine Maus hin? Wo...wo steht das?
Twitch Plays Maus.
Ach, hier.
Ich kla...ich...ich glaube nicht,
dass er seine Methodennamen
wirklich...wirklich Deutsch macht.
Das ist mit Sicherheit für den Stream.
Weil es gibt doch Lichtelemente und lokales Licht.
Ey, jeder wie er will. Das sagt überhaupt nichts aus.
Ihr könnt ihn doch mal fragen. Wir hosten ihn jetzt.
Und ihr könnt ihn doch mal fragen,
warum seine Methodennamen
auf Deutsch sind.
Macht ihn aber nicht gleich schlecht.
Sagt es mal den Franzosen,
die alles auf Französisch schreiben.
Seid nett, Leute.
Seid nett.
Also, Leute. Bis denn. Macht's gut.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss. See you.